et bien bonjour à tous et bienvenue en
direct sur public Séna en direct de la
salle des conférences de la Haute
Assemblée ici nous sommes à quelques
mètres de l'hémicycle et toute cette
matinée et bien public Scéna va vous
faire vivre en direct l'un des moments
importants de cette session Parlement
ire puisque on va examiner on va
regarder on va écouter les débats autour
de la réforme territorial c'est un
moment très important de ce texte
aujourd'hui puisque les sénateurs et les
sénatrices et bien vont
devoir dire ce qu'il pense des
conclusions de cette fameuse commission
mixte paritaire qui a eu lieu la semaine
dernière qui est passée de justesse on a
envisagé un texte commun entre les deux
assemblées l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat sur ce texte crucial qui réforme
l'avenir des collectivités locales qui
met en place vous le savez certainement
ce fameux conseiller territorial qui va
remplacer les conseillers généraux et
les conseillers régionaux un texte qui
modifie également les compétences des
différents strates des collectivités
territorial un texte où une fois de plus
ici au Sénat et bien ce seront les
centristes qui auront le dernier mot qui
seront les clés de cette affaire les
clés de ce vote sur cette réforme des
collectivités locales avec avec moi à
mes côtés Nicolas Abou il préside le
groupe centriste ici au Sénat vous allez
intervenir dans quelques minutes dans
l'hémicycle quel est l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui de votre groupe au début de
cette discussion cruciale le groupe est
très partagé ça fait maintenant donc
plus d'un an qu'on travaille sur ce
sujet le gouvernement avait au départ
déposé trois textes différents
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un texte
contenant le bloc
collectivité commune intercommunalité
sur sur lequel nous sommes totalement
d'accord ne devait pas figurer le mode
de scrutin du conseiller territorial
désormais il figure sous pression des
députés le gouvernement est obligé de
céder nous n'y étions pas favorable nous
souhaitions renvoyer même si nous sommes
d'accord sur le fond sur la création du
conseiller territorial apparaît aussi
sous pression des députés un bloc
compétenence dieu merci lors de la
commission mixte paritaire nous avons
réussi à renvoyer sa mise en œuvre euh
très loin puisque 2015 2015 c'est-à-dire
après les élections présidentielles
après les élections législatives et donc
si vraiment dans sa forme ce bloc devait
être maintenu c'est que tout le monde
serait d'accord donc nous considérons
que nous avons tout de même obtenu des
choses importantes depuis cette année de
travail et en commission mixte paritaire
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui va se jouer
véritablement le rôle du Sénat
et c'est pourquoi la majorité de du
groupe centriste votera certainement ce
texte même si l' autre moitié de notre
groupe se répartira en vote contre et en
et en abstention considérant qu'on
aurait peut-être pu aller plus loin en
tant que président de groupe je pense
que nous avons déjà obtenu beaucoup et
que il serait dommage de de tout gâcher
en laissant le dernier mot à l'assemblée
qui ne manquerait pas de revenir sur un
texte beaucoup plus différent plus dur
par rapport à celui que souhaitait le
Sénat est-ce que le Sénat va peser de
tout son poids dans ce texte on le sait
le Sénat est prioritairement compétent
en en matière de réforme en matière de
texte de loi sur les collectivités
territoriales oui moi je souhaite
véritablement que nous pions et que ce
nos avancés restent orors c'est pour ça
que je ne souhaite pas du tout l'échec
de cette lecture même si je suis très
inquiet quant au résultats que nous
allons obtenir aujourd'hui mais je pense
que mon collègue président du groupe
RDSE a bien fait aussi de déposer une
proposition de loi tendant à accorder le
dernier mot au Sénat à l'avenir
lorsqu'il s'agira de texte touchant les
collectivités territoriales et bien
j'espère qu'on trouvera une
majorité pour adopter cette réforme
constitutionnel c'est bien difficile
est-ce que sur un texte comme celui-ci
ce matin ici au Sénat c'estàdire les
conclusions d'une commission mixte
paritaire le texte peut encore être
amendé peut encore bouger il peut être
amendé sur proposition d'un
parlementaire mais avec l'accord du
gouvernement uniquement je crois que
nous sommes dans une situation où tout
ce qui pourrait faire bouger le texte
est de nature à déstabilis
éventuellement les équilibres et je
crois qu'il faut il faudrait mieux
attendre les textes à venir qui nous
sont annoncés pour éventuellement
compléter le texte actuel alors vous le
voyez Nicolas Abou il y a beaucoup de
monde autour de nous ce texte va
rassembler nombre de sénateurs et
sénatrices ici dans l'hémicycle on a vu
également bris ortefeu le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui viendra défendre au nom
du gouvernement ce texte dans quelques
minutes maintenant dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat est présent également Michel
Mercier de je vous disait de nombreux
sénateurs et et sénatrices on va se
retrouver donc tout au cours de de de
cette patinée pour pouir vous faire
vivre pardon les débat autour de ce
texte majeur vous avez entendu
certainement les roulements de tambour à
quelques mètres de mois ce que ce qui
veut dire euh comme il est de tradition
que le président de séance et bien va
prendre place dans ce qu'on appelle vous
le savez ici le plateau qui correspond
au perchoir à l'Assemblée nationale hein
c'est le le le le fauteuil du Pr
président du Sénat une séance donc
extrêmement importante politiquement et
également
euh très importante pour l'avenir je
vous disais des collectivités locales je
rappelle que ce texte et bien met en
œuvre une réforme voulue par le
président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozi une réforme qui a déjà fait vous
nous le rappeliez tout à l'heure Nicolas
Abou déjà fait l'objet de deux lectures
ici au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale un texte avec une comment
dirais-je un parcours extrêmement
chaotique Ave avec peut-être un épilogue
ce matin on écoute tout de suite c'est
jean-Patrick Courtois qui est le
rapporteur du texte ici au Sénat qui
prend la parole et Nicolas Abou et bien
vous la prendrez dans quelques minutes
merci en tout cas de d'être venu tout de
suite la parole à jean-Patrick Courtois
en direct pour la confiance que vous
m'avez témoigné et l'appui que vous
m'avez apporté ainsi qu'à vos
collaborateurs de cabinet le directeur
général et les fonctionnaires de la
direction des collectivités locales pour
leur capacité d'écoute et leur
participation
à l'élaboration du texte à vous monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
pour votre aide et vos conseils dans la
recherche de la solution la plus adaptée
au problèmes posés ainsi qu'au
fonctionnaires de la Commission des lois
pour les conseils qu'il m'ont prodigué
pour leur patience leur sens de l'écoute
et leur très grand professionnalisme
dans la rédaction des amendements dont
un grand nombre d'entre eux ont marqué
le texte de l'empreinte du
Sénat en effet composé de trois volets
principaux ce texte vise respectivement
à mettre en place des consillers
territoriaux moyen d'améliorer la
coordination entre départements et
régions sans remettre en cause les
spécificités de chacune de ces
collectivités territoriales à améliorer
le fonctionnement de l'intercommunalité
et à clarifier les principes encadrant
la répartition des
compétences tout au long de ces travaux
le Sénat s'est attaché à préserver les
libertés locales à favoriser un
fonctionnement harmonieux de la
République décentralisée à accroître la
capacité des collectivités et
l'efficience de leur cadre
d'intervention les dispositions restant
en discussion soumises à la commission
mixte paritaire qui s'est réunie je le
rappelle le 3 novembre dernier étit de
nature très diverse en matière
électorale le point central du texte est
naturellement la création des
conseillers territoriaux c'est-à-dire
d'une nouvelle catégorie d'élus qui
exercera en un seul mandat les fonctions
actuelles de conseiller général et de
conseiller
régional cette réforme ne remettra pas
en cause l'autonomie des départements et
des régions dont les décisions resteront
prises par des instances
spécifiques je tiens à souligner comme
j'ai déjà eu occasion l'occasion de le
faire au sein de cet hémicycle que la
création des conseillers territoriaux
témoigne de la confiance du Sénat envers
les élus locaux en effet la création des
conseillers territoriaux n'a pas eu pour
but de réduire le nombre d'élus
ni de porter atteinte à leurs
compétences bien au contraire nous avons
eu à cœur de faire en sorte que ce texte
permett de conforter les élus locaux et
de rappeler qu'ils sont le ciment de la
décentralisation ainsi en dotant les
élus des départements et des régions de
compétences plus nombreuses nous avons
voulu qu'il soit plus écouté plus
légitime et mieux identifié par les
citoyens je rappelle d'ailleurs que la
création des conseillers
qui Figur dans l'article 1er du projet
de loi a été adopté par les deux
assemblées dans les mêmes termes dès la
première lecture ceci montre l'adhésion
du Parlement à cette innovation pour
autant on ne peut pas nier que les
dispositions relatives au consillers
territoriaux été profondément modifié
depuis que les Sénat été sais du texte
en janvier dernier à cet égard je tiens
àigner que c'est notre Haute
Assemblée première a estimer que la
question des modes de scrutin ne devait
pas être traité dans un texte à part et
qui a en conséquence rapatrié cette
question au sein du projet de loi de
réforme des collectivités territoriales
en effet il ne nous a pas semblé
opportun de créer une nouvelle catégorie
d'élus sans déterminer les principales
caractéristiques de leur mode d'élection
ce choix ce choix était un choix de
sagesse et il a été respecté par
l'Assemblée nationale celle-ci n'a pas
souhaité que les conseillers
territoriaux soit élu dans un mode de
scrutin mixte comme le Sénat l'avait
initialement prévu et elle a préféré
qu'il soit désigné comme le sont les
actuels conseillers généraux
c'est-à-dire avec un scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours ce mode de
scrutin apprécié des français a en effet
l'avantage de la lisibilité et de la
clarté il garantira que les électeurs
soient pleinement en accord avec leurs
élus cependant comme nous le savons tous
le mode de scrutin uninominal
majoritaire pose de graves problèmes
matière de parité l' risqu donc d'être
les grandes perdantes de cette réforme
grâce à l'action du Sénat ce risque a
été écarté lors de la deuxème lecture et
lors de la commission mixte paritaire
c'est en effet à l'initiative des
sénateurs et notamment du groupe
centriste que des sanctions
particulièrement dures sans précédent
dans notre législation ont été institué
à l'encontre des partis qui aur investi
plus d'hommes que de
femmes le système retenu par la CMP sur
proposition de notre collègue i de
trigne est ainsi nettement plus sévère
et nettement plus incitatif que le
mécanisme que les députés voulaient
mettre en place enfin la commission
mixte paritaire a adopté un tableau de
répartition des conseillers territoriaux
tenant compte à la fois des exigences du
Sénat de ne pas diminuer à l'excès le
nombre d'élus locaux et de l'Assemblée
réduire au maximum les écarts de
représentation par rapport à la moyenne
régionale le tableau ainsi défini est à
la fois équilibré et pragmatique pour le
volet intercommunal l'empreinte du Sénat
a été conservée par l'Assemblée
nationale qui a approfondi les
orientations impulsées par la Haute
Assemblée premièrement l'adoption du S
du système sénatorial pour la
composition des conseils communautaires
qui désormais seront élus au souffrage
universel direct par le biais d'un
système de fléchage des membres des
organes délibérants des EP à fiscalité
propre deuxièmement l'amélioration des
outils d'élaboration de la carte
intercommunale troisièmement le
renforcement des pouvoirs de la
Commission départementale de la
coopération intercommunale tant pour
l'élaboration du Schéma départemental et
la vie des intercommunalités que pour la
mise en œuvre des dispositifs
temporaires d'achèvement et de
rationnalisation de la carte
intercommunale et enfin qurièmement par
la préservation de l'autonomie
budgétaire et financière des communes
membres d'une métropole
la réforme des modalités de désignation
des délégués communautaires tout d'abord
permettra de renforcer la démocratie
locale et de rénover le fonctionnement
des conseils communautaires la montée en
puissance du fit intercommunal
osé en effet que ceux qui prennent les
décisions au sein des EPCI soi
directement responsable de leur action
devant les citoyens et que les électeurs
puissent contrôler leur action je tiens
à souligner que cette réforme ambitieuse
est soutenue par toutes les grandes
assation d'élus communaux et
intercommunaux dans ce cadre il me
semble important de rappeler que le
Sénat était l'artisan principal du
nouveau système d'élection des
conseillers communautaires en effet
alors que le projet du gouvernement
prévoyait l'application automatique d'un
tableau pour la détermination du nombre
de sièges de conseillers communautaires
et la mise en place d'une règle
strictement arithmétique pour répartir
ses sièges le Sénat a introduit la
possibilité dans les communautés de
communes et dans les communautés
d'agglomération de conclure des accords
locaux pour déterminer ces deux éléments
ce faisant notre Haute Assemblée a
préservé le caractère consensuel et
partenarial de l'intercommunaité ces
choix ont été partagés par les députés
qui n'ont modifié le système créé par le
Sénat qu'à la marge j'en viens au
métropole le Sénat a validé
l'institution de cette nouvelle
catégorie de PCI à fiscalité propre la
plus intégrée de toutes mais il en a
modifier le régime pour respecter
l'autonomie communale rappelons que la
Haute Assemblée a maintenu au maire sa
compétence en matière d'autorisation
d'urbanisme et introduit la notion
d'intérêt métropolitain déterminé à la
majorité qualifiée des 2/ers pour
transformer les équipements elle a
supprimé le transfert de la fiscalité
communale à la métropole à l'initiative
de votre commission qui avait adopté en
ce sens un amendement de nos collègues
Gérard Colomb et Jacqueline gouau ce
faisant le Sénat a aligné le régime
fiscal des métropoles sur celui des
communautés urbaines enfin il a prévu un
accord unanime des conseils municipaux
pour autoriser le transfert de la DGF
des communes à la métropole alors que
rappelons-le le projet de loi prévoyait
un transfert obligatoire en 2e lecture
l'Assemblée nationale a globalement
validé le dispositif voté par le Sénat à
l'exception des modalités entourant
l'adoption du pu métropolitain la CMP a
retenu l'article 5 consacré aux
métropole dans cette rédaction sous la
réserve de coordination technique pour
achever et rationaliser
l'intercommunalité l'assemblée a reporté
du 1er mars d'être retenue par le Sénat
2e lecture au 30 juin 2013 le terme des
dispositifs temporaire la commission
mixte paritaire a décidé de concilier
les motifs anagonistes des deux
assemblées en le fixant au 1er juin 2013
cette date prend en compte tout à la
fois la proximité des élections
municipales et la ité de permettre au
préfet d'achever les procédures de mise
en œuvre de la carte le Sénat a enfin
approuvé le dispositif des pôles
métropolitains autre novation du projet
de réforme qui consacre l'intelligence
locale tout en précisant son régime
juridique à l'initiative de votre
commission des Lois et sur la
proposition de Gérard Colomb il a
déterminé le mode de répartition des
sièges au sein de l'organe délibérant du
pôle métropolitain pour tenir compte du
poids démographique de chacun de ses
membres ce régime a été modifié par les
députés pour l'essentiel en abaissant de
120 à 50000 habitants la population de
leepci le plus important requise pour la
création d'un pôles frontalier venons-en
au régime de fusion des communes
renouvelées que la Haute Assemblée a
accepté sans optimisme excessif la
commune nouvelle elle a cependant
modifié le dispositif proposé par le
gouvernement pour consacrer l'adhésion
volontaire des communes au principe de
la fusion les députés avaient assoupli
les conditions de création d'une commune
nouvelle princip principalement pour
l'appréciation des résultats de la
consultation populaire lorsqu'il serait
procédé sur l'ensemble du périmètre
concerné en revanche ils ont fini par
valider le régime financier des communes
nouvelles que le Sénat avait
profondément modifié en supprimant le
dispositif incitatif proposé par le
gouvernement la dotation particulière et
en adoptant une garantie de dotation de
solidarité rurale la commission mixte
paritaire sur ma proposition a rétabli
l'appréciation des résultats de la
consultation des habitants en l'absence
de demande unanime des conseils
municipaux au niveau de chacune des
communes concernées pour créer une
commune nouvelle comme l'avait prévu le
Sénat ainsi aucune commune ne pourra
être fusionnée contre son gré en
première lecture afin de remédier à des
dysfonctionnements locaux le Sénat a
instauré un système de retour à
l'autonomie des communes associées dit
Marcelin à l'initiative de notre
collègue Jean-Pierre Sueur l'amendement
de votre rapporteur précisant les
modalités et les conditions de retrait a
été adopté malgré les refus je dois
encore rappeler l'exigence qui a guidé
nos travaux toujours associé les
collectivités territorial et leur
population aux décisions qui les
concernent fidèle à cette logique et et
à l'initiative de plusieurs sénateurs du
groupe RDSE le Sénat a reconstruit le
procédure de regroupement des régions
des départements prévu dans le projet de
loi initiale pour la subordonnée à
l'accord unanime de l'ensemble des
assemblées locales et à l'adhésion de la
majorité de la population il a aussi su
faire place à l'initiative de plusieurs
sénateurs aux spécificités des
territoires de montagne à l'initiative
de notre collègue ambroise Dupont notre
Assemblée a sécurisé les contrats de
pays actuellement en cours afin d'éviter
que la suppression de la seule catégorie
juridique des pays n'entraîne leur
remise en cause j'en viens maintenant au
vol les compétences les interventions
des régions et des département au nom de
la clause générale de compéten bien que
pertinente et utile à nos concitoyens
dans beaucoup de cas connaiss aussi il
faut l'admettre certaines dérives qu'il
importait de voir teles qu'elles sont
enchevêtrement des actions redondance de
certains investissements complexité
excessive des financements c'est
pourquoi l'objectif de clarification des
compétences qui est l'un des buts
poursuivi par ce projet de loi est
légitime encore faut-il éviter tout
bouleversement de la gestion locale et
toute mise en péril des services publics
locaux or le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale s'il présentait des
innovations intéressantes ne nous a pas
semblé à s prendre garde à ses écueils
c'est pourquoi la Sénat l'a amendé en
profondeur en seconde lecture
l'Assemblée nationale ayant ensuite
rétabli une grande partie de son texte
il fallait que les préoccupations
manifestées par notre Haute Assemblée
soi à nouveau exprimées en commission
mixte paritaire les dispositions du
texte qui vous est soumis ont ainsi été
sur nos propositions profondément
modifiées par rapport au texte issus de
la seconde lecture de l'Assemblée
nationale au lieu d'une mise en
application des 2012 des dispositions
relatives à la répartition des
compétences la commission paritaire sur
ma proposition a substitué la date du
1er janvier 2015 ce choix est d'ailleurs
cohérent avec la vision de la
coopération entre les niveaux de
collectivité portés par ce texte
coopération qui s'appuiera
essentiellement sur la création du
conseiller territorial la commission
paritaire a également adopté un
amendement proposé par notre collègue Yv
de trig qui insère une clause de
revoyure ainsi une nouvelle loi devra
permettre de réajuster la répartition
des compétences entre les collectivités
territoriales au plus tard dans 2 ans et
demi dans le même esprit aucune nouvelle
règle d'encadrement des cofinancements
ne s'appliquera finalement avant le 1er
janvier 2015 mieux encore à à compter de
l'entrée en vigueur du dispositif il
serira moins de contraintre les
collectivités que de les inciter à
coopérer par le biais de l'élaboration
du Schéma régional d'organisation des
compétences les collectivités
territoriales établiront ainsi librement
leur propre charte de coopération en
matière d'intervention au profit du bloc
communal les exceptions prévues en en
faveur de la culture du sport et du
tourisme s'appliqueront quant à elle à
comptter de 2015 enfin la participation
minimale des collectivités territoriales
aux investissement dont assure elle-même
la maîtrise d'ouvrage a également été
ramené par notre intervention
à 20 % quelle que soit la taille de la
collectivité considérée en effet établir
un montant minimal différent en fonction
du nombre d'habitants de la commune ou
de leepci ne nous a pas paru pertinent
bien entendu les exceptions en faveur de
la rénovation urbaine de la réparation
des dégâts d aux calamités publiqu et
des monuments protégés ont été maintenus
sur ce dernier point je tiens d'ailleurs
à préciser que la formulation retenue
couvre naturellement les travaux
d'entretien de réparation et de
restauration terme usuel mentionnés dans
le code du patrimoine pour l'heure mes
chers collègues je vous propose
d'adopter le projet de loi de réforme
des collectivités territoriales dans le
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
parur notre vote mes chers collègues et
j'en suis intimement convaincu répondra
aux enjeux posés pour l'avenir de la
décentralisation et confortera la
vitalité de la démocratie locale colonne
vertébrale de notre société je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Briss ortefeu ministre de
l'Intérieur de l'outremaire et des
collectivités
territoriales on va
voir vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs bon nous nous
retrouvons donc ce matin dans le cadre
de la procédure d'approbation du texte
élaboré par cette commission mix
paritaire qui s'est réuni donc mercredi
dernier alors je vais pas reprendre la
présentation détaillée des équilibres
qui sont dégagé lors de cette CMP votre
rapporteur vient de vous les présenter
de manière très claire très précise très
exhaustive mais je vis saisir l'occasion
qui m'est offert puisque nous arrivons
au terme de ces débats parlementaires de
saluer la qualité du travail accompli
par la commission des lois et tout
particulièrement par son président et
son rapporteur je n'oublie pas non plus
la contribution des rapporteurs pour
avis qui se sont exprimés au cours de
nos débats je me bornerai simplement si
vous voulez bien à deux remarques
première remarque le vote de ce matin ou
de cet après-midi marque l'aboutissement
d'un long travail conjoint voici un peu
plus de 2 ans le président de la
publique confi au Premier ministre
Édouard Baladur le soin de présider un
comité regroupant des personnalités
faisant tout à la fois autorité venu
d'horizon politique et professionnel les
plus divers et les conclusions de le
rapport formaient le point de départ
d'une longue phase de concertation qui
s'est également appuyé sur les très
nombreux rapports publics consacrés ces
dernières années à l'indispensable
nécessité de moderniser notre
organisation territoriale je pense
d'ailleurs et en particulier aux travaux
menés par la mission temporaire du Sénat
sur l'organisation et l'évolution des
collectivités territoriales présidé par
le sénateur Claude bot le Premier
ministre a consacré deux conférences
nationales des exécutifs à la réforme
territoriale des groupes de travail
entre l'État et les représentants des
collectivités se sont réunis tout au
long du printemps 2009 et au cours de
l'été et de l'automne 2009 à avec Alain
marlex et Michel Mercier nous avons reçu
l'ensemble des présidents des
associations nationales d'élus ainsi que
l'ensemble des présidents des formations
politiques représenté au Parlement
français et européens pour échanger sur
la réform puis l'examen parlementaire
s'est engagé le gouvernement a fait un
choix c'est celui de ne pas recourir à
la procédure accéléré et ce sont donc
près de 60 he en commission et 200 he de
débat en séance publique qui ont donc
été consacrés à l'examen de ce projet au
cours des deux lectures dans chacune des
deux chambres un débat a eu lieu un
débat ouvert libre démocratique un débat
qui n'a été ni précipité ni tronqué et
un débat qui d'ailleurs n'a pas été
médiocre les discussions à l'évidence
ont été denses les débats ont été
souvent minutieux tous les
parlementaires naturellement qu'il
souhaitai ont pu s'exprimer et la
discussion parlementaire a fait évoluer
le texte de manière décisive sur de très
nombreux aspects et ça sera d'ailleurs
ma deuxème remarque et la dernière je
pense qu'avec le texte élaboré par la
CMP nous sommes parvenus à trouver un
bon équilibre sur de très nombreux
points la voix du Sénat a été entendu et
s'est imposé dans le respect du système
bicaméral qui est le are c'est vrai sur
l'intercommunalité le Sénat a fixé dès
la première lecture le nouveau régime de
répartition des sièges au sein de nos
intercommunalités en préservant la
possibilité d'un accord local et
l'Assemblée nationale s'y est
rallé de la même façon le calendrier du
processus d'achèvement et de
simplification de
l'intercommunalité a été raccourci pour
le distinguer de éché des élections
municipales de mars 2014 comme vous en
aviez exprimé clairement et à juste
titre le souhait c'est vrai également
sur les communes nouvelles puisque
conformément au souhait du Sénat leur
création nécessitera soit l'unanimité
des conseils municipaux soit une
consultation populaire positive dans
chacune des communes concerné c'est vrai
aussi sur les métropoles ou c'est bien
la Haute Assemblée qui a fixé le curseur
entre le respect de l'indépendance
notamment l'indépendance financière des
communes et la nécessité de bâtir un
statut plus intégré pour nos grandes
agglomérations c'est vrai aussi sur les
compétences et les cofinancements où le
Sénat a privilégié une harmonisation de
la date d'entrée en vigueur des articles
au moment de l'élection des futurs
conseillers territoriaux et il a œuvré
aussi pour assouplir les règles
d'encadrement des financements croisé et
en outre le Sénat a veillé à définir un
mécanisme d'évaluation de ce dispositif
qui débouchera ensuite sur une loi qui
pourra le préciser et l'adapter en tant
que besoin et c'est vrai enfin sur le
mécanisme des sanctions financières
infligées aux partis politiques qui ne
respecteraient pas l'objectif de parité
puisque vous avez souhaité et à juste
titre territorialiser et durcir ces
sanctions pour les rendre encore plus
effectives à l'issue de nos débats
chacun est bien sûr libre de se faire sa
propre opinion mais l'essentiel c'est de
tenir le cap que la majorité s'est fixé
et c'est le cas puisque nous assurons
trois avancé d'abord les communes sont
confortées elles sont confortées comme
les cellules de base de notre
organisation territoriale ell conservent
leur autonomie leur compéten générale au
service des habitants à l'avenir elles
devront inscrire systématiquement leur
action dans un cadre intercommunal
rénové démocratisé qui doit davantage
favoriser la mutualisation des moyens et
elles seront renforcées grâce à la
coopération intercommunale dans le cadre
d'un dialogue apaisé serein approfondi
entre les élus et le préfet
ensuite les régions et les départements
seront amenés à mieux travailler
ensemble grâce à la création des
conseillers territoriaux qui est un acte
de confiance envers les élus dans la
leur capacité à simplifier à clarifier
et accélérer l'action publique locale au
plus près de la réalité des territoires
enfin le texte fixe un cadre national
cohérent et péren pour l'exercice des
compétences des collectivités et la
répartition de leur financement tout en
préservant la capacité des élus de
l'adapter au vu de certaines spécificité
locale donc mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs arrivés au terme de l'examen
parlementaire de ce projet de loi je
voudrais remercier l'ensemble des
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui ont
participé à nos débats à souvent avec
une grande compétence parfois avec
passion et en tout cas toujours avec
conviction je crois pouvoir affirmer que
le texte qui vous est soumis ce matin
porte clairement la marque et
l'empreinte de la haute assemblée qui
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
République selon les termes de notre
Constitution et je souhaite à présent
que votre assemblée puisse l'approuver
et apporter son soutien à une réforme
pragmatique et que je crois utile utile
pour nos élus locau utile pour nos
concitoyens et certainement utile pour
notre pays je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
discussion générale n'étant pas organisé
les dispositions de l'article 29 aléa 3
du règlement s'applique il est donc
attribué un temps global de 2 he et dans
la suite de notre discussion générale la
parole est maintenant au président
Nicolas Abou
és vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues plus d'une année après le
dépôt sur le bureau du Sénat de quatre
textes portant réforme des collectivité
nous examinons aujourd'hui les
conclusions de que la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est Ré mercredi
dernier en octobre 2009 le gouvernement
s'est engagé à mettre en œuvre un
calendrier de réforme en 4 temps cette
méthode devait permettre de poser un à
un les jalons d'une réforme dont la
nécessité reconnu sur tous les bancs au
lieu de s tenir le gouvernement a
préféré céder à la pression de
l'Assemblée nationale et prêter le flan
à des critique
légitime les questions électorales
devaient être débattu dans le projet de
loi numéro 61 cédant au députés le
gouvernement donc a bousculé le
calendrier et nous le regrettons sur un
sujet aussi important il e été
préférable de prendre le temps
nécessaire à une meilleure
concertation la clarification des
compétences devait faire l'objet d'un
texte
ultérieur sur ce sujet également nous
regrettons que la parole donnée au Sénat
n''est pas été
tenue légitimement on peut critiquer non
seulement le calendrier mais aussi la
méthode par laquelle certaines dispos éé
intr dans ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat a le sentiment
justifié que son rôle de représentation
constitutionnelle des collectivités
territoriales n'a pas été pleinement
respecté et nous regrettons
profondément je salue d'ailleurs la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle de
nos collègues du
RDSE visant à donner le dernier mot au
Sénat sur les projets de loi relatifs
aux collectivités territoriales
au-delà de cette initiative bienvenue
messieurs les ministres nous vous
demandons qu'à l'avenir la parole donnée
au Sénat soit tenue et que les
engagements pris devant nous soient
respectés cela évitera que comme
aujourd'hui l'adoption par le Sénat
d'une réforme si nécessaire soit en
péril car cette réforme mes chers
collègues est
nécessaire l'ensemble des sensibilités
qui s'exprime au sein de notre
groupe dans son principe à la création
du conseiller
territorial comme l'indiqué il y a
quelques mois le président du Mouvement
démocrate il s'agit moins de diminuer le
nombre de nos élus locaux que de mieux
coordonner l'action des deux niveaux de
collectivité pour élire les futurs
conseillers territoriaux en mars
2014 nous avons fait des proposition
pour introduire une part de
proportionnelle comme l'avait prévu
aussi le
gouvernement
après deux lectures devant notre Haute
Assemblée nous avons fait le constat
qu'il n'existait pas même s'il y en a
qui s'en
revendiqu le constat qu'il n'existait
pas à ce jour de majorité pour adopter
une dose de
proportionnelle nous
l'acceptons en revanche nous comprenons
mal l'attitude des déput des députés
s'agissant c'est nous qui sommes
députés oui mal l'habitude des députés
s'agissant du seuil s'agissant du seuil
permettant le maintien au second tour
des élections
cantonales modifier les règles d'une
élection quelques mois seulement avant
sa tenue nous semble très malvenu et
profondément contraire à notre tradition
républicaine notre dernier sujet
d'inquiétude relatif au conseiller
territorial concererné le respect de la
parité sur ce point soyez rassuré notre
membre titulaire de la lors de la
commission mixte paritaire y a obtenu
une modification visant à rendre le
dispositif d'incitation financière au
respect de la
parité parle on parle du respect de la
parité vous pouvez peut-être respecter
déjà la démocratie le droit de parole
des autres
poursuivezésent ça me gêne donc
respectez les autres si vous souhaitez
voir la parité respectée respectez ceux
qui
parlent notre dispositif
oui taisez-vous laissez un peu parler
celui qui a la parole notre dispositif
consiste à appliquer à l'ensemble des
départements d'une région la diminution
de financement la plus importante
atteinte dans un des départements de
cette région correspondant donc au plus
grand écart observé entre le nombre de
candidats et de candidats cela incitera
les partis politiques à veiller au
respect de la parité dans tous les
départements sans
exception concernant
l'intercommunalité tant l'achèvement de
la carte de l'intercommunalité que
l'élection des délégués communautaires
au suffrage direct doivent être salué il
me semble d'ailleurs qu'on s'en félicite
sur tous les bancs le travail du Sénat
été primordial sur ces sujets tout
particulièrement l'assouplissement des
règles de répartition des délégués
communautaires la position de notre
haute assemblée a également été respecté
sur les conditions de création d'une
commune
nouvelle enfin concernant la
clarification des compétences les
dispositions introduites par l'Assemblée
restaient inabouties pour de nombreux
membres de notre groupe elles sont en de
ça de ce que l'on pouvait attendre mais
en CMP nous avons obtenu et je remercie
à nouveau des traines c'est que c'est
l'entrée en vigueur de ces dispositions
soit reporté au 1er janvier
2015 je considère que nous avons obtenu
satisfaction car en 2015 2015 c'est loin
la majorité qui sortira des prochaines
échéances électorales aura tout le temps
et le loisir de modifier ses disposition
si cela lui apparaît nécessaire ou
souhaitable 2015 c'est aussi après
l'élection des premiers conseillers
territoriaux ainsi ce sont les élus
eux-mêmes ceux qui siègeront à la fois
la région et département qui élaboreront
les schémas territoriaux d'organisation
de
compétence nous avons également
renforcer la clause de revoyure qui
permettra par une nouvelle loi de
corriger de compléter le dispositif dans
l'année qui suivra sa mise en œuvre soit
en
2016 le texte issu de CMP enclenche un
mouvement de
clarification de la répartition des
compétences entre chaque niveau de
collectivité il
enclenche le bon mouvement dans la bonne
direction grâce au report d'application
que nous avons
imposé toutes les volontés qui
souhaitent aller plus loin auront
amplement le temps d'y revenir et
d'aller
au-delà en matière de cinancement la CMP
nous a également permis d'obtenir des
améliorations importantes tout d'abord
le seuil minimal de participation pour
le maître d'ouvrage d'un projet est
maintenu à 20 % au lieu du seuil fixé à
30 % par l'Assemblée nationale
ensuite l'interdiction de bénéficier
d'un cumul de subvention à défaut
d'adoption dans la région du schéma
d'organisation de compétence a été
repoussé à
2015 sur ce point comme sur celui des
communes nouvelles l'Association des
maires de France a indiqué que ses
attentes étaient
satisfaites mes chers collègu cette
avancée mais plus largement tout le
travail du Sénat a été salué par les
associations d'élus il doit être
préservé pour cela il nous appartient de
ne pas laisser le dernier mot à
l'Assemblée
nationale lors de l'examen des
conclusions de la mission Bel nous
soulignons par la voix de notre collègue
Jacqueline gourau que la nécessité d'une
réforme faisait consensus au Sénat et
oui à l'époque elle disait même
l'intercommunalité a montré que les
consciences évoluaient dans le temps je
me souviens des rétisciences disait-elle
initiale et elle elle s'adressait à
Monsieur chevenenman en disant monsieur
chevenman vous les avez sans doute pas
oublié vous non plus et
l'intercommunalité disait a fait
l'unanimité même si cette réussite est
encore susceptible
d'amélioration et bien mes chers
collègues en conclusion elle nous
indiquit que nous tous sénateurs nous
étions prêts aujourd'hui un an et demi
de travail et de débat et de
propositions plus tard cela reste vrai
les sénateurs sont prêts nous sommes
prêts à enclencher le mouvement de
réforme à préservver le travail et les
améliorations obtenues au Sénat c'est la
raison pour laquelle une majorité de
sénateurs Union centriste votera pour
l'adoption de ce texte je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant au
présid la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Jean-Pierre
suer ça va 7 minutes 7 minutes avec un
peu de TVA si tu veux tu es gentil merci
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues je pourrais bien
sûr revenir sur tout ce qui nous oppose
à ce texte le conseiller
territorial qui symbolise la
confusion qui Instit iser si cela était
voté le cumul des
mandats le conseiller
territorial qui aurait pour effet de
départementaliser les régions alors que
nous voulons des régions fortes plus
fortes dans le contexte européen et
international qui est le nôtre mais qui
en même temps se traduirait par la mort
lente des département
même si on n'en parle pas nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec cela nous ne sommes
pas d'accord non plus mes chers
collègues avec la
recentralisation rampante monsieur le
ministre que nous voyons à presque
chaque article quelle différence avec ce
mouvement et ce souffle de la
décentralisation qui était voulu par
François mitteran pierre Morrois et
Gaston de fer c'est vraiment autre chose
mes chers collègu et on le sent bien et
on l'a vu à chaque étape du débat je
pourrais redire tout ce que nous avons
déjà dit sur le refus de la parité le
recul en matière de parité qui pour nous
est quelque chose d'absolument
essentiel mais mes chers chers
collègues je vais préférer
revenir sur les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire car il y a
une question qui se pose à tous les
sénateurs à toutes les sénatrices quel
que soit notre place dans cet
hémicycle
regardons les conclusions de la CMP et
posons-nous chacun et chacune la
question suivante est-il raisonnable de
souscrire à ces conclusions quand nous
avons voté ce que nous avons voté ici au
Sénat et il me semble que l'examen
objectif de ces conclusions
amène une conséquence très claire c'est
que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter les conclusions de cette CMP
pourquoi j'aborderai trois
points premièrement la question de la
parité dont je viens de parler qui
a-t-il dans le texte de la
CMP il y a une
disposition obscur complexe
allambiqué
incompréhensible sur le financement des
partis politiques dans les régions et
dans les départements mes chers
collègues y a-t-il ici un seul sénateur
une seule sénatrice qui pense que cette
disposition puisse avoir un effet
quelconque en matière de parité nous
savons bien que non nous savons bien que
cela n'aura aucun effet et je dirais
même que c'est mépriser la parité qui
est une grande conquête que de croire
que l'on peut défendre la parité avec
ces obscures règles de TR dont vous
savez qu'elles n'auront aucun effet
sur aucun parti politique de ce pays et
si quelqu'un ici pense le contraire je
le remercie de nous fournir les
arguments qui pourrai nous convaincre il
n'y en a pas deuxièmement en matière de
compétence mes chers
collègues ici même au terme de long
débat il y a eu un vote du Sénat un vote
essentiel nous avons jugé
ensemble je dis ensemble par
335 voix pour 5 voix contre que le texte
qui nous était présenté en matière de
compétence ne convenait absolument pas
nous envoyons tous les jours les
inconvénients ce texte ne convient pas
et la position du Sénat de tous les
groupes du Sénat a été de dire il faut
renvoyer cela à une autre loi
donnons-nous le temps d'en parler
sereinement parce que ce qui est
présenté n'est ni fait ni AFF faire ça
ne marche pas nous le voyons tous les
weekends dans notre départ dans au
département quand on nous explique les
grandes difficultés auxquelles seraient
confrontés les maires si on adoptait
cela
3335 voix mes chers collègues nous
arrivons à la commission mixte paritaire
et alors après des débats confus il
apparaît que telle mesure sera
reportter durant quelques temps mais qui
peut ici souscrire à cela de deux choses
l'une mes chers collègues ou bien nous
légiférons vraiment comme cela a été le
cas pour toutes les grandes lois de
décentralisation sans exception et nous
voyons loin nous bâtissons quelque chose
de stable de solide sur quoi nous
pourrons nous appuyer mais ce n'est pas
le cas là on nous dit telle mesure ne
s'appliquera qu'en 2015 les autres en
2012 en 2013 2014 on n'y comprend plus
rien c'est la confusion la plus totale
c'est du bricolage vous le savez ici
tout le monde le sait mes chers
collègues qui va prendre la parole pour
dire ce bricolage est une grande loi de
la République mais
personne je sais que vous pensez tous
cela alors tirez-en les conséquences mes
chers collègues et enfin et ce sera le 3
et dernier argument il s'est passé cette
chose
incroyable par rapport au
seuil nous sommes arrivés il y a eu un
vote au moment de ce vote la commission
mixte paritaire avait
échoué et puis elle était elle avait
presque
échoué
presque et
puis et Monsieur yest et puis le miracle
est
arrivé alors dans la
loi il y
a au moins égal à 12,5
% après une suspension de séance et
j'aimerais connaître quel est l'auteur
anonyme qui a eu cette trouvaille
incroyable nous sommes passés monsieur
le ministre vous nous avez quitté
quelques temps monsieur marlex comp nous
sommes mais vous êtes revenus nous
sommes heureux de vous retrouver vous
vous rendez compte monsieur le ministre
nous sommes passés de au moins égal à
12,5 % à égal au moins à 12,5 % alors là
mes chers
collègues c'est un sa politique sur la
TV là monsieur le Président un sursut
idéologique une avancée et PU mologique
tout change tout va de l'avant mais
c'est une
palinodie c'est ridicule vous le savez
tous et si le Sénat se déjuge en vertu
de cela qui ne ressemble à rien et bien
vraiment personne ne le comprendrait mes
chers collègues nous ne vous demandons
qu'une chose nous demandons aujourd'hui
que le Sénat soit fidèle à
lui-même il est pas là ma
bon je
rappellerai la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jacques
mard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique social européen mon cher
collègue ça va avez la
parole
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues il est des
réformes auxquelles on peut prédire une
longue vie que l'on partage ou non leurs
objectifs tel n'est pas le cas du texte
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui confus
complexe inachevé sauf dans ces visés
partisanes et dont la révision profonde
s'imposera
naturellement nous avons participé au
débat ici même avec l'espoir et l'envie
d'aboutir à une œuvre consensuelle de
grandes convergences pouvez nous
rapprocher la simplification progressive
de la structuration de nos collectivités
autour de trois
pôles la facilitation du processus de
fusion la finalisation de la carte
intercommunale le développement de la
mutualisation une réelle péréquation une
fiscalité locale plus juste la révision
des bases nous pouvions envisager une
recherche d'une certaine spécialisation
des compétences en évitant les doublons
nous pouvions entendre que depuis 10 15
ans les concours de l'État au
collectivité avait fortement augmenté et
que cela ne pouvait durer pour se faire
il convenait de commencer par le début
faire le bilan de la décentralisation
cher à Adem Hervé mettre à plat la
réalité des transferts de charges mais
aussi les charges imposées par l'État
aux
collectivités monsieur le ministre
marlex me reprochez récemment et
courtoisement comme à l'habitude d'avoir
en tant que président d'agglomération
refuser de cofinancer la route nationale
122 est- ce bien
raisonnable comme de demander à nos
communautés moyennes de financer les
centres universitaires liges aériennes
bientôt les aras nationaux et j'en
passe vous avez commencé par la fin pour
d'autres
raisons vous avez en supprimant la taxe
professionnelle par un monstre
technocratique incontrôlé et
incontrôlable définit une nouvelle
fiscalité avant de réformer les
collectivités vous avez modifié le
calendrier électoral
avant même de faire voter le principe de
la dite réforme puis vous avez malaxès
sans vergogne plusieurs projets de loi
en faisant passer les articles de l'un à
l'autre au mépris de toute logique en
fonction d'intérêt
d'opportunités
stratégique il ne fallait pas parler de
mode de scrutin dans le projet 60 sauf
pour monsieur le Président àout ni de
répartition des compétences
le projet de loi 61 est devenu
l'arlaisienne et là aussi j'en
passe nous sortions de la mission Belot
avec une base de travail
consensuelle avec le souci de valoriser
le rôle du Sénat nous avions écouté le
président du Sénat tout cela pour être
mené en bateau jusqu'au brutal passage
en force en
CMP vous avez traité la fracture
territoriale par la
de la rupture seul moyen pour vous de
soigner la
République le Sénat est le premier à
sortir blessé de ce
gâi par des artifices procéduraux vous
avez réussi à contourner l'article 39 de
la
Constitution privilégiant le rôle du
Sénat dans les textes touchant les
collectivités d'où la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle du RDSE pour renforcer
la fonction présentation par le Sénat
des
collectivités le Sénat mes chers
collègues a été humilié tant par la
chronologie invraisemblable de ces
textes que par l'introduction devant
l'Assemblée nationale d'amendements
fondamentaux non discutés en première
lecture par notre assemblée tant par des
réticences coupables comme le refus de
communiquer au Sénat le tableau des
conseillers territoriaux que vous avez
dévoilé ensuite à
l'Assemblée humilié aussi par le
feuilleton rocambolesque du mode de
scrutin humilié par le dernier acte de
la CMP malgré la grande dignité du
président y tout cela ne pourra que
laisser le goût d'une amertume
indélébile devant tant de
partialité d'arrogance de renoncement de
certains la
transmutation très bien décrite par
notre collègue Jean-Pierre Sueur de
l'article 1B de au moins égal à 12 et5i
% à égal au moins à 12 et5i % et le
changement du résultat du vote en
découlant mérite de rejoindre vite les
oubliettes du
parlementarisme cette
loi cette loi mes chers collègues nous
l'espérons trépassera avant de
vivre car elle ne répond pas au
véritables enjeux d'avenir de nos
collectivités le jour où vous avez voulu
inoculer le conseiller territorial dans
le tissu de nos
collectivités organisme hybride qui va
les déstabiliser les masques sont
tombés parce que le conseiller
territorial n'a pas pour objectif de
simplifier le fonctionnement des
collectivité il a une vocation
politique diminuer le poids des régions
et changer la représentation politique
il est clair que les présidents de
région seront à la merci des accords ou
dés acccords des présidents de conseil
généraux surtout le motif politique du
nouveau système électoral à savoir et
disons-le l'élimination du Front
national a en fait pour conséquence la
confortation de votre parti majoritaire
qui n'aura plus à redouter de
triangulaire et pourra encore davantage
brider des alliés
soumis pour les communistes pour les
veres cur d'amaigrissement garanti quant
aux radicaux vous arriverez enfin à
votre objectif d'éradication mais mes
chers collègues centristes vous nous
suivrez de peu dans la
tombe
l'évolution de vos déclarations et
positions sur le mode d'élection de ce
conseiller teritorial et révélateur dans
le projet de loi 61 première proposition
scrutin à un seul tour avec
proportionnel dans le texte 60
apparition de l'amendement 645 du
président Abou par un scrutin uninominal
l'expression du pluralisme politique et
la représentation démographique par un
scrutin proportionnel ainsi que la
parité au même moment vous rejetiez
dédaigneusement notre amendement
introduisant le scrutin uninominal à
deux tours je vous cite monsieur le
ministre Mercier je ne peux émettre un
avis favorable car le conseiller
territorial assure la représentation des
citoyens avant celle du
territoire nous connaissons la suite à
l'assemblée nationale verba volante
j'avais déjà souligner que l'acceptation
au Sénat de l'article 1a était un Sirot
pour faire avaler la pilule à ceux qui
toussaient aujourd'hui ils ont toute
raison de
s'étouffer sur les autres dispositions
discuté en CMP que ce soit la
désignation des délégués des communes et
les observations pleines de bon sens de
Jean-Pierre chevenem le démontreront sur
le fléchage sur la représentation des
petites communes et le travail de leur
mère qui seront fragilisé heureusement
il y a les dispositions de l'article 34
B a sur les compétences des
collectivités il n'a été tenu aucun
compte du vote très majoritaire du Sénat
en 2è lecture en fixant une compétence
d'attribution par catégorie des
collectivités sauf pour le sport la
culture le tourisme avec report
maintenant au 1er janvier 2015 et comme
d'habitude une évaluation revoyure au
bout de 2 ans
relevons qu'une fois de plus les
communes de plus de 3500 habitants et
les EPCI de plus de 50000 seront
malheureusement fragilisés dans leurs
investissements au terme de ce débat mes
chers collègues le Sénat n'est plus la
maison des territoires chers à son
président et ce par un détournement de
l'esprit de la Constitution la nouvelle
architecture
territoriale relève du baroc non
flamboyant nous voulions la
simplification nous avons une
complexification et un arsenal de futurs
conflits et litiges et peut-être le plus
grand charcutage électoral à venir nous
voulions une avancée démocratique vous
excluez des départements et des régions
la représentation politique de tous les
courants à l'exception de deux d'entre
eux nous continuons à attendre ce qui
était le plus urgent comme dans la
société moins d'injustice entre les
territoires et entre les contribuables
locaux pour toutes ces raisons la
majorité de notre groupe et tous les
radicaux de gauche ne voteront pas ce
texte
merci merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant notre
collègue madame Iliane
assassie voilà voilà vous venez
d'entendre Jacques Mar au nom du groupe
RDSE le groupe radical ici au Sénat sur
cette réforme territoriale vous le savez
les sénateurs et sénatrices débattre en
ce moment des conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire qui a eu lieu
la semaine dernière et qui a abouti à un
compromis hein sur ce texte compliqué ce
texte complexe de réforme des
collectivités locales on a entendu tout
à l'heure brisortefeu le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Collectivités locales
vter le travail du Sénat sur ce texte en
disant que le Sénat et bien avait
imprimé sa marque sur ce texte essentiel
pour l'avenir des collectivités locales
mais on a également entendu l'opposition
qui a dénoncé l'humiliation faite au
Sénat je reprends là en substance les
propos de Jean-Pierre Sueur qui a eu un
discours extrêmement combatif contre ce
texte à mes côté Jean-Jacques y le
président UMP de la commission des lois
que je remercie d'être avec nous
Jean-Jacques yest sur cette place sur
cette marque sénatoriale sur ce texte
une marque qui est visiblement contextée
par l'opposition qu'en pense le
président de la commission des lois
alors c'est une caricature puisque le
notamment tout ce qui concerne le volet
intercommunalité c'est vraiment le Sénat
et d'ailleurs c'était à peu près les
propositions de la Commission Belot faut
le rappeler la commission sénatoriale
mis en place à l'époque hein vous savez
c'est préservation de de l'autonomie des
communes et de leurs décision c'est vrai
pour les métropoles c'est vrai pour les
intercommunalités et ça c'était vraiment
le Sénat parce que certains trouvaient
que les petites communes n'avaient plus
d'intérêt et étaient prêt à faire des
réformes comme ça comme elles ont existé
dans d'autres pays européens pour
diminuer sensiblement le nombre des
communes et nous on a dit on a réaffirmé
et Ctait la le travail du Sénat c'est
réaffirmer le rôle de la commune et bien
entendu la nécessité aussi pour les
communes de s'associer pour des grands
projets et pour aussi gérer mieux les
services publics à la fois plus
économiquement et aussi offrir de
meilleurs services aux habitants
notamment en zones rural donc il y a la
pâte sénatoriale euh en tout cas sur ce
point-là dans ce texte alors c'est un
contex stable alors en ce qui concerne
les compétences honnêtement euh on avait
dit on reporte à une autre
loi autre loi qu'il aurait été très
difficile de de de de de préparer
pourquoi parce que les compétences sont
déjà attribué par la loi euh une
compétence en matière de collège c'est
le département les lycées c'est la
région moi ce que je ce que j'aurais
souhaité c'est qu'on révise et qu'on
permette peut-être de modifier les
choses surtout avec le nouveau conseil
territorial est-ce que les lycées ça
aurait pas pu être confiés au
département c'est une c'est une question
qui a été posée et qui avait été posée
par de nombreux groupes de
travail pardon l'assemblée a souhaité
qu'on fixe des
principes mais en fait ça ne me remet
pas en cause du tout l'idée du Sénat de
dire on fera le point il y aura le
schéma entre la région et le département
et puis on pourra faire une loi pour
préciser les choses donc c'est c'est pas
si éloigné que cela les deux points de
vue ne sont pas si éloignés que ça alors
reste le conseil territorial là écoutez
politiquement moi je suis pour le
scrutin majoritaire à de Tours parce que
je pense que c'est le plus juste et et
qui permet je le rappelle dans les
départements de corriger les inégalités
car en matière cantonale ça va de 1 à 45
la représentation alors si on trouve que
ce système était juste et qu'il fallait
pas le réformer je trouve que c'est une
c'est une mauvaise quurelle il aurait
fallu de toute façon faire la réforme
des cantons et et moi je crois beaucoup
que la coopération entre les élus euh
territoriaux qui seront à la fois
chargés de de de l'élément de proximité
qui est le département et quiapouvé
depuis de siècles sa pertinence et la
région qui qui permettra de réaliser
ensemble les grands projets qui
dépassent le département je pense que
c'est une réforme positive et une vraie
réforme de simplification de nos
institutionsors locales justement sur
cette idée de simplification
l'opposition dénonce on l'entendait
encore il y a quelques instants un texte
confus un texte exc extrêmement complexe
est-ce que finalement euh l'idée de de
départ voulu entre autres par le
Président de la République de simplifier
ce fameux millefeuille administratif
français de simplifier les procédures
les compétences entre les différents
strates territoriaux est-ce que où où
est la vérité est-ce que ce texte est
véritablement simplificateur et là
encore je m'adresse au président de la
commission des lois qui je le rappelle
faisait partie de cette fameuse
commission mixte paritaire la semaine
dernière qui a œuvré sur la mise en uvre
d'un texte de compromis un texte commun
sur cette complexité monsieur YaST alors
si on est de bonne foi en fait c'est
c'est quand même une simplification
puisqueen fait il y a deux échelons
important qui est la commune et le
département et puis il y a deux échelons
qui sont délégués c'est une coopération
qui est la région et et
l'intercommunalité alors en fait si on
si on clarifie tout ça alors on me dit
il y a les métropoles mais les
métropoles c'est c'est une coopération
intercommunale abouti beaucoup plus
abouti que les communautés urbaines ou
que d'ailleurs il y a plus il y a les
communautés urbaines les communautés
d'agglomération et communautés de
communes donc c'est une nouvelle forme
on verra bien d'ailleurs s'il y en a
beaucoup moi je souhaite que ça soit les
très grandes agglomérations et qu'on
descende pas trop d'ailleurs c'est
500000 habitants mais je pense que là il
y aura peut-être une un problème de
euh entre la région et la métropole mais
après tout c'est ceux qui seront les
plus dynamiques qui gagneront et après
tout une compétition sur des territoires
c'est pas forcément négatif moi je pense
que c'est une réelle simplification quoi
qu'on en dise et et on verra d'ailleurs
euh et d'ailleurs quand on dit que on a
le système le plus complexe d'Europe
c'est pas tout à fait vrai parce qu'il y
a toujours un échelon de base alors
comme une intercommunalité il y a
toujours un échelon intermédiaire de
proximité et il y a toujours un échelon
de région qui fait les grandes qui fait
les grandes opérations à la fois de
reconnaissance économique vis-à-vis des
tiers et aussi de grandes
infrastructures on retrouve à peu près
partout sous des formes différentes une
structure qui sera celle désormais de
notre organisation territoriale alors on
le sent hein lorsqu'on écoute les bas
ils sont euh une fois de plus passionnés
dans l'hémicycle de la Haute Assemblée
ce ce matin Nicolas Abou qui était à
votre place et d'ailleurs l' redit à la
tribune tout à l'heure le président du
groupe centriste indiquait que une
majorité de son groupe centriste
voterait en faveur de ce texte mais
est-ce que cette majorité euh centriste
sera suffisante pour euh que ce texte
soit finalement adopté ça va être
icracle encore bah je l'espère alors moi
ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est que
partout hein euh il y a ceux qui disent
je suis réformateur mais en fait ils ne
veulent que rien change pourquoi parce
que souvent ils sont dans quelque fois
ils sont dans leur petit royaume hein
moi j'ai été président de conseil
général donc je sais ce que c'est euh ou
ou ou ou président de d'intercommunalité
et bien oui mais on n'est jamais dans
son royaume si on veut faire une réforme
il faut dépasser ce qu'on aime bien
après tout c'est normal puisqu'on y est
habitué pour passer à autre chose je
reconnais que c'est un peu difficile
mais
s'adapter pour les collectivités
d'ailleurs c'est comme pour les
individus s'adapter c'est ne pas mourir
merci beaucoup Jean-Jacques yest
président de la commission des lois ici
au Sénat le débat se poursuit c'est je
crois Ian Assassi
sénatriste de sensani qui est
actuellement à la tribune on écoute dans
la foulée l'intervention attendue du
président du groupe UMP Gérard Longuet
un texte passionnant et en tout cas des
débats passionné ici dans la haute
assemblée sur ce texte de la réforme des
territoires à 2015 ne changera rien au
désastre à venir et je ne parle pas de
l'étranglement financier des
collectivités mon ami et collègue
Bernard verra y reviendra le fil
conducteur de cette réforme c'est la
logique libérale celle de quelques
intérêts privés contre l'intérêt général
mes chers collègues l'article 24 de la
Constitution fait de notre assemblée la
représentante des collectivités locales
elle ne serait pas dans son rôle
si sa majorité adoptait un texte en
contradiction avec les choix
majoritaires qu'elle a elle-même exprimé
au nom de mon groupe je vous demande
donc de ne pas valider le texte qui nous
est soumis et pour notre part parce que
notre boussole et la réponse aux besoins
et aux aspirations de nos concitoyens
concitoyens nous voterons bien
évidemment contre ce texte merci mes
chers
collègues la parole est maintenant au
président Gérard Longuet pour le groupes
de l'Union pour un mouvement
populaire mes chers collègues monsieur
le Président messieur les ministres mes
chers collègues il est tout à fait
exceptionnel que notre hémicycle soit
aussi fourni de collègu de qualité à
l'occasion du vot
d'un commission mixte
paritaire mais nous sommes un
rendez-vous historique pour notre
assemblée et la question qui se pose
avec simplicité la
suivante avons-nous l'intention nous
sénateurs de laisser à d'autres le soin
de prendre la main en matière de réforme
des collectivités locales et pour cette
raison et pour cette raison chers
collègues je le dis avec conviction
j'invite le groupe de l'UMP dans sa
totalité à soutenir les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sans ce
soutien que j'espère unanime nous
laisserions à l'Assemblée nationale qui
a certainement qualité et compéten mais
qui n'a pas notre culture et notre
expérience le chin de construire cette
étape de la réforme des collectivités
locales c'est la raison pour laquelle
regardons ensemble avec tranquillité les
conclusions de cette CMP j'ai écouté
avec intérêt jean-patric courtois qui a
dit des choses vraies fondé sur son
expérience et je voudrais à cet instant
le saluer pour son implication
personnelle et pour les travaux conduits
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois par la par votre commission
j'ai écouté avec étonnement Jean-Pierre
sur car j'avais le sentiment qu'il nous
parla
d'un autre texte d'un autre
rendez-vous et qu'au fond sa dialectique
aait pour seul objet de nous rappeler
qu'il ne pouvait pas combattre ce
maillon nouveau que nous apportons à la
construction à la réforme à la
modernisation des collectivités locales
et qu'il cherchait dans des accidents de
la commission mixte paritaire un
prétexte pour justifier son ref V d'un
avancement qui se situe dans la culture
française de décentralisation raisonnée
réfléchie construite certes avec force
par les lois de fer en
1982 mais prolongé et appliqué d'une
façon constante et en particulier par la
culture par la connaissance et par
l'engagement de notre haute assemblée
car c'est bien là le la difficulté que
nous avons à gérer ensemble
nous avons ici dans cet hémicycle sans
doute le maximum de compétences
rassemblé sur le thème des collectivités
locales nous avons assurément et les
chiffres parlent de même le maximum
d'expérience en matière de collectivité
locale ce qui veut dire chers collègues
et en particulier me tournant vers mes
amis de l'UMP le maximum de diversité
dans cette compétence et dans cette
expérience or nous devons venir à
l'unité nous avons tous des raisons à
travers nos expériences personnelles
j'aiété 13 ans conseiller général 12 ans
président de Région j'étis naturellement
conseil municipal et dans la majorité et
dans l'opposition nous avons tous des
raisons de regarder les collectivités
locales à l'ône de notre propre
expérience et de souhaiter qui le
département qui l'intercommunalité qui
la métropole qui même le pays dont
certains ont apporté sur nos territoires
de véritables avancées de de souhaiteer
que l'organisation des collectivités
locales se construise sur son expérience
personnelle ce que nous vous demandons
aujourd'hui chers collègues à l'occasion
de ce vote c'est de se rassembler sur
deux évolutions simples qu'aucun d'entre
vous ne peut combattre raisonnablement
ces deux évolutions simples c'est
d'achever
l'intercommunalité qui est assurément
une grande réussite française lorsque
nous avons ouvert le débat au sein du
comité baladure il y a eu de beaux
esprits extérieurs et notamment
permettez-moi de le dire dans la presse
qui découvre à l'occasion et par
exception tous ne sont pas compétent sur
ce sujet les collectivités locales des
références un benchmarking européen qui
semblait faire de la France une sorte
d'arriéré parce que poursuivant
indéfiniment l'héritage des paroisses
voire même de l'ancien régime c'est
exactement le contraire dans une société
française qui cherche ses repères les
collectivités communales de base sont
sont assurément la première porte
d'accès à la vie publique celle qui
permet à chacun de nos compatriotes et
en particulier les plus faible d'entre
eux d'avoir un interlocuteur c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
ministre vous avez eu raison de porter
au plus loin l'intercommunalité car
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Chevenement votre
travail était remarquable nous avons
souhaité maintenir les communes qui est
cette solidarité française mais leur
donner définitivement la la dimension de
l'intercommunalité pour être certain
puisse assumer les services publics
qu'elles doivent rendre à leurs
compatriotes nous avons à travers ce
texte de l'intercommunalité apporté une
réponse durable qui marie à la fois une
tradition une expérience française une
proximité une solidarité en quelque
sorte une humanité qui est celle de
notre territoire en faisant en sorte que
ces 36000 communes travaillent demain
dans ces 2000 intercommunalité dont nous
savons au travers de cette loi qu'elles
seront généralisées mais qu'elles
respecteront cette réalité communale cet
engagement de femmes et de hommes qui et
d'hommes qui sur le terrain permettent à
la vie locale d'exister et c'est nous
qui le faisons et vous ne pouvez pas le
contester et d'ailleurs très sincèrement
au cours des débats et j'ai suivi tous
les débats le groupe socialiste n'a pas
contester cette action en faveur de
l'intercommunalité car il sait
parfaitement que nous avons eu le
courage de faire ce qu'il n'a pas su
faire lorsqu'il était au
gouvernement je voudrais
revenir sur la deuxè et là encore chers
collègues nous avons tous des
intercommunalités différentes les uns
vivent leur intercommunalité communale
de montagne avec quelques milliers
d'habitants d'autres gèrent de grandes
communautés urbaines mais cette
diversité la loi la reconnaît la loi la
respecte et s'il y a quelques
imperfections je me retrouve vers un ami
que j'aime beaucoup s'il y a quelques
imperfections et bien la loi nous aurons
l'occasion inlassablement comme nous
l'avons fait dans ce travail de
construction des collectivités locales
de remettre sur le chantier tel ou tel
aspect qui aurait pu manquer à l'examen
du législateur dans le texte précédent
le système n'est pas fermé mais le
principe général est sain il est durable
c'est de construire l'intercommunalité
en respectant la commune là où certains
d'entre vous chers collègues socialistes
voulaient supprimer la commune en
assurant l'élection directe au suffrage
universel des conseils communautaires
alors aujourd'hui à la veille du congrès
des maires vous l'oubliez mais c'était
bien dans vos textes dans vos
programmes
merci merci chers collègues de me donner
l'occasion de défendre le deuxème point
issu de la commission mixte paritaire
c'est le conseiller
territorial alors le conseil
territorial il y a une réalité
française la vie
quotidienne la vie quotidienne
lorsqu'elle n'est plus communale lorsque
l'intercommunalité cède la main repose
sur le département j'ai été pendant 12
ans président de Région chacun d'entre
nous sait chacun d'entre nous sait qu'un
responsable un président d'association
un chef d'entreprise va presque toutes
les semaines à la préfecture du
département il va reconnaissons-le bien
moins souvent à la préfecture de région
on doit défendre la région pour ce
qu'elle apporte être une un
rassemblement de territoire qui permet à
la France des provinces d'être respecté
de Paris car pendant très longtemps
Paris en effet aimait discuter avec des
communes isolées avec des départements
perdus voire avec des circonscriptions
mais lorsqu'il a fallu négocier avec des
régions fortes des sujets majeurs comme
par exemple les itinéraires autoroutiers
les lignes de TGV à ce moment-là Paris
les ministères les administrations
centrales le Conseil général des Ponts a
rencontré de véritables interlocuteurs
qui avaient l'autorité pour représenter
les territoires vis-à-vis de Paris mais
non pas sur l'extrême quotidien mais sur
les grands projets universitaires les
grands projets d'infrastructure les
grands projets de filière économique
c'est le rôle de la région cela ne veut
pas dire que région et département
s'opposent cela veut dire qu'ils se
complètent mais elles sont différent il
fallait apporter une réponse je pense
que la valeur ajoutée la plus originale
de ce sex monsieur le ministre c'est en
effet sauver le conseil général qui est
un élu de proximité que chacun d'entre
nous connaît que chacun enentre nous
apprécie parce qu'il a non mais monsieur
le Président on peut parler dans cette
assemblée non parce que si ça vous
intéresse pas
sortez et si vous voulez vous comporter
comme des députés partisan essayez de
vous faire élire à l'Assemblée nationale
mais ne venez pas
ici poursuivez monsieur le
Président le conseiller général ne
souffre que d'une seule faiblesse
l'extrême diversité de son assise
démographique peut-on raisonnablement
penser que des collectivités qui gèrent
près de 4 % du PIB les départements et
dont la vocation sociale la vocation
culturelle la vocation de soutien de
proximité ne peut que se maintenir
puisse continuer d'être géré par des
assemblées qui reposent sur une
extraordinaire diversité de la
représentativité des femmes et des
hommes qui le composent le Conseil
constitutionnel nous demandait de
réviser les assises cantonales pour
abandonner l'héritage révolutionnaire et
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une certaine
proximité démographique dans la
représentativité des conseillers
généraux c'est exactement ce que ce
projet de loi propose sauver le Conseil
le conseiller général en lui donnant une
assiette démographique équilibré et vous
avez eu l'intelligence monsieur le
ministre nous n'y avons nous n'y avions
nous l'avions côtoyé dans le comité
Baladur sans le formaliser de faire en
sorte que ces rapprochement démographiqu
fonctionne non seulement dans le cadre
départemental mais aussi dans le cadre
régional de telle sorte que l'élu le
plus familier de nos compatriotes après
le maire le conseiller général puisse
être à la fois le gestionnaire respecté
du département parce que représentant
des assises démographiques comparables
mais soit pour les domaines de compéten
de la région le l'élu qui représente en
effet les territoires au sein de
l'ensemble régional et c'est ce
conseiller territorial qui va assurer
l'unité dans la diversité du département
et des régions nous avons donc un
système qui tente à la rationalité c'est
un système qui s'éloigne des solutions
magiques nous avions eu au début de
cette réflexion des donneurs de leçons
extérieures qui ne connaissent rien à la
vie locale et qui d'int trit plume à
partir de leur réflexion nationale et
internationale voir cosmique nous
explique qu'il faut supprimer ceci ou
cela nous sommes partis de notre
expérience de terrain nous sommes partis
de l'histoire de notre pays nous sommes
partis de l'histoire de notre République
des étapes franchies successivement et
vous avez retenu une idée monsieur le
ministre que nous soutenons c'est que le
conseiller territorial est en effet le
trait d'union entre cette vie locale qui
gère au quotidien et qui soutient au
quotidien la vie de nos compatriotes
dans le cadre du département et qui
rassemblé en assemblée régionale sera
l'interlocuteur puissant et donc
respectter des décisions nationales qui
trop souvent prises à Paris s'appuyait
sur la compétition des territoires voir
les guerres P crocolines entre petite
métropoes local et jouant de les des
oppositions historiques pouvait prendre
des décisions qui n'étaient en rien
celles des terr teroire nous en avons
trop souvent souffert dans nos régions
pour ne pas nous réjouir qu'enfin les
territoires soient rapprochés
réconciliés pour être vis-à-vis de Paris
des interlocuteurs respectés dont les
administrations centrales et les grandes
entreprises devront prendre en
considération leur position je voudrais
à cet
instant conclure par une réflexion de
simple nous sommes dans une logique
d'effort continue il n'y a pas de
solution miracle il n'y a pas de bing
bang il n'y a pas de grand soir des
collectivités locales il y a le respect
d'une expérience issue du terrain avec
une volonté de rationaliser alors cher
Nicolas Abou en effet tout n'est pas
totalement satisfaisant y compris
d'ailleurs pour les sénateurs membres de
l'UMP en particulier nous ne ressentions
pas comme les députés le ressentent
l'extrême obligation d'impos poser une
clause de 12 et5i % des inscrits pour
accéder au deuxème tour parce que nous
connaissons la vie locale et nous savons
qu'une certaine dispersion n'a jamais
nuit j'ajoute Jean-Pierre suer vous nous
dites il y a pas de parité c'est un
recul qu'est-ce qui quelle est la
différence la différence c'est qu'en
effet le scrutin uninominal ne ne rend
pas certaine la parité comme le scrutin
proportionnel la rend certaine mais
auriez-vous donc tant peur du Parti
socialiste et de sa culture que vous
pensiez être incapable de représenter
des femmes pour les les candidates au
Conseil
Territorial puisque nous
sommes vous avez donc cette certitude
vous avez la certitude que vos
candidates étent mauvaise et que et que
les candidates issu des listes
régionales ne pourraient pas devenir
demain des candidats du conseiller du
conse des candidats conseill territorial
mais c'est tout à fait invraisemblable
de ce pessimiste ou alors il cache il
cache la certitude d'une culture
misogyne que vous assumez tranquillement
devant
nous nous nous avons nous nous avons
tout simplement renvoyé à la loi
61 le soin de fixer le niveau à partir
duquel la proportionnelle jouera pour
les collectivités locales et pourquoi
avons-nous fait ce report pourquoi
avons-nous adopté ce report et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il faudrait les
maires s'expriment plus clairement
encore qu'ils ne l'ont fait jusqu'à
présent l'Association des maires de
France a retenu le chiffre de le seuil
minimum de 500 habitants pour la
proportionnelle mais l'Association des
communes rurales nous dit que c'est à
partir du premier habitant qu'il faut la
proportionnelle et bien il n'est pas
complètement anormal pour des élus qui
ont l'ambition de représenter les
collectivités locales de donner aux
associations d'élus locaux le temps de
fixer le chiffre qu'il préfèrent et nous
faisons en en adoptant cette attitude
nous respectons ceux qui nous mandatent
dans cette assemblée que les élus
locaux de que les élus locaux communaux
que l'AMF se metent d'accord et nous
prendrons dans le cadre de la loi 61 la
plus grande considération d'un point de
vue dès lors qu'il serait enfin
convergent j'ajoute enfin sur la
proportionnelle comment peut-on
raisonablement et je le dis à mes amis
centristes qui ont la tentation de ne
pas voter ce texte je
nous n'avons rien moi je suis de culture
libérale je viens de l'UDF et je n'ai
rien et contrairement à certains de mes
amis Gaulistes je n'ai rien contre la
proportionnelle aux élections
législatives et je considère en
particulier que le système allemand est
sans doute l'un des systèmes les plus
pertinents qu'il soit mais dans une
élection territoriale il convient de
représenter des hommes et les femmes
ainsi que des kilomètres carré et si
vous adoptez la proportionnelle vous
gommez la représentation de l'espace
sauf cher Jacqueline Gouro à faire des
élections par petit secteur géographique
ce qui aboutit on l'a vu en 1986 lorsque
François mitéran avait rétabli la
proportionnelle en réalité avoir dans
l'immense majorité des cas une élection
majoritaire au bénéfice des deux grands
partis car le nombre d'élus n'est pas
suffisant pour que la proportionnelle
fonctionna réellement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle parce que nous défendons
les territoires et parce que le
ramassage scolaire parce que l'aide aux
personnes âgées à domicile est le même
qu'il y ait des habitants qu'il n'y en
ait pas nous considérons que les
territoires à faible population ont
aussi le droit d'être représentés dans
les assemblés départementales et
régional l'application de la
proportionnelle les prix vrais de cette
représentation voilà l'ensemble des
raisons pour lesquels chers collègues de
l'UMP chers collègues centristes je
n'attends pas de grandes surprise du
groupe soci du groupe communiste mais je
vous demande dans un rendez-vous qui est
historique que le SDA garde la main sur
la réforme des collectivités locales et
qu'il adopte les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire merci
monsieur le
Président
merci la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Hervé Moray
groupe de l'Union
centristevez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues je ne reviendrai pas par
manque de temps sur les évolutions d'une
réforme qui devait être ambitieuse et
qu'à ce titre là nous soutenions car
elle devait clarifier et simplifier les
compétences elle devait réduire le
millefeuil territorial elle devait
générer des économies elle devait
améliorer la lisibilité des politiques
publiques je ne reviendrai pas non plus
toujours par manque de temps sur les
mauvais coups portés au Sénat au fil des
lectures je rappellerai simplement que
si nous avons voté ce texte en deuxè
lecture à une courte majorité une
majorité de 6 voix avec 18 voix du
groupe de l'Union centriste c'est parce
que nous avions obtenu satisfaction sur
un certain nombre de points nous avions
obtenu à la quasi unanimité du Sénat le
renvoi de la question des compétences à
une loi spécifique à la fois parce que
nous n'admettons pas que ce sujet a été
introduit dans le texte par voie
d'amendement à l'Assemblée nationale
alors qu'il devait être introduit par un
texte spécifique ici même mais aussi et
surtout parce que les articles 35 et
suivants n'apportent pas la
clarification qui nous était
promise nous avions obtenu également le
rejet du mode de scrutin uninominal à
deux tours pour désigner les conseillers
territoriaux alors c'est vrai président
Abou l'a dit le Sénat ne s'est pas mis
d'accord sur un mode de scrutin
alternatif puisque la gauche et l'UMP
ont conjointement rejeté le scrutin
mixte et non pas le scrutin
proportionnel que nous avions proposé il
fallait donc me semble-t-il aborder
globalement la question des modes de
scrutin dans le projet de loi 61 comme
c'était d'ailleurs initialement prévu et
à ce titre je tiens à rappeler notre
opposition à restauration du scrutin de
liste dans les communes des 500
habitants c'est un seuil beaucoup trop
bas et l'ensemble des maire que l'on
peut rencontrer nous le
confirme nous avions également obtenu
avec le le soutien du gouvernement et
notamment du ministre de l'Intérieur que
je remercie la prise en compte des
fonctions de président de PCI dans la le
calcul du cumule des mandats enfin nous
avions obtenu des améliorations en ce
qui concerne la parité
l'Assemblée nationale a en quelques
heures de débat auquel l'opposition n'a
d'ailleurs pas jugé bon de participer
fait table race de notre travail et
force de constater que le texte issu de
la CMP est largement plus proche de
celui de l'Assemblée nationale que de
celui du
Sénat le mode de scrutin uninominal à
deux tours avec un seuil de 12 et demi%
pour se maintenir au 2è tour est inscrit
dans le texte l'article 3 5 concernant
les compétences et de retour c'est vrai
avec une clause de rendez-vous
permettant de l'adapter mais on sait ce
qu'il devient des clauses de rendez-vous
et je trouve je dois dire un petit peu
cocasse de vouloir absolument régler
dans ce texte la question des
compétences alors qu'on nous app qu'on
nous explique qu'elles ne s'appliqueront
qu'au 1er janvier 2015 c'est-à-dire dans
4 ans je pense que 4 ans ça nous laisser
le temps de voir sérieusement cette
question quant à la question du cumul
des mandats elle a comme par ench
disparu seul le dispositif de la parité
a été amélioré et fort heureusement
également le texte de l'Assemblée sur
les communes nouvelles qui pouvaent
conduire à l'intégration de communes
dans une commune nouvelle contre leur
volonté fort heureusement ce dispositif
a été revu alors je voudrais vous dire
simplement monsieur le ministre et très
franchement messieurs les ministres que
je considère que le compte n'y est pas
quant aux aspirations exprimées par le
Sénat et vous ne pouvez pas me
semble-t-il demander au Sénat de voter
et en même temps ne pas tenir compte de
ses positions et j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas l'argument selon lequel il
faudrait voter un texte qui ne nous
convient pas uniquement parce qu'il ne
faut pas que l'Assemblée nationale le
vote j'avoue que c'est une logique de
l'absurde qui m'échappe alors pour
conclure je voudrais simplement vous
dire messieurs les ministres que vous
seul pouvez encore amender ce texte et
donc à nouveau je vous demande de de
prendre en compte les demandes du Sénat
sur la question des modes de scrutin et
je dis bien des modes de scrutin sur la
question des compéten ou sur celle du
cumul que vous aviez ici même soutenu
monsieur le ministre et le président du
groupe UMP gERARD LONGUET avait soutenu
ma proposition dès la première lecture
je veux donc encore rester confiant
monsieur le ministre sur la capacité du
gouvernement entendre le Sénat qui je
vous le rappelle est de par la
Constitution le représentant des
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie de m'avoir accordé quelques
secondes de plus monsieur président
merci mon chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jean-Claude
Perronet groupe
socialiste vous avez la
parole monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
lorsqu'au tout début de son premier
septenénat François mitteran a décidé
d'entamer le processus de réformes
institutionnelles connu sous le nom de
décentralisation les choses étaient
claires elles étaient claires parce que
le chef de l'État de l'époque puis les
députés élus après dissolutions avaient
cet objectif inscrit dans leur programme
comme il l'avait se dit en passant sur
le départ à la retraite à 60 ans les
deux campagnes électorales avaient
notamment porté sur ces thèmes et nul ne
pouvait prétendre ne pas être informé de
ce qui allait se passer les choses
étaient claires parce que les objectifs
étaient ouvertement affichés rapprocher
les centres de décision de la population
pour éviter l'engorgement administratif
et améliorer ainsi la rapidité et la
qualité des décision on visait donc
l'efficacité et une transparence plus
grande garantie au niveau financier par
le contrôle à postériorie des chambres
régionales des comptes c'est un
dispositif qui après la violente
opposition de la droite parlementaire
fut rapidement consensuel je dis bien
consensuel et j'ai pu mesurer tout à
l'heure en écoutant monsieur Longuet
combien ce consensus pouvait aller loin
puisqu'il accapare des réformes aussi
majeures qui ont été portées par la
gauche comme celle de la
l'intercommunalité car monsieur chevenem
qui est présent est bien le père de la
loi de 1999 et non monsieur Longuet et
l'UMP donc un dispositif consensuel un
dispositif évolutif amélioré ou en tout
cas complété par les lois donc de 99 et
de 2003 200004 il s'est avéré efficace
et ne soulevait pas d'objection globale
jusqu'à ce que le président de la
République tout à sa frénésie
prétendument réformatrice pardon ne
s'aviss de le bouleversé en prenant pour
modèle un gabarit européen qui n'existe
nulle part dans le régime de pouvoir
personnel que nous connaissons où le
Parlement ne joue pas assez son rôle de
contrôle et se contente le plus souvent
par sa majorité de valider les les choix
de l'exécutif on pouvait penser que les
choses iraient vite et sans anicroche ce
n'est pas tout à fait ce qui s'est passé
en tout cas en apparence et il convient
donc de regarder ce qui reste du projet
proposé et de le mesurer à l' des à l'Ô
des objectifs avoués ou non de
l'exécutif dans tous les cas et dans
cette perspective en particulier il faut
distinguer l'essentiel de l'accessoire
chacun l'appréciant d'ailleurs de façon
différente rappelez-vous il s'agissait
de s'attaquer au mythique millefeuilles
moyen en quoi au lieu de simplifier on a
créé des niveaux supplémentaires et par
exemple plus d'une douzaine de
possibilités de
groupements communaux il s'agissait de
limiter le nombre des élus accusés de
gabgi cet objectif n'a été que
partiellement atteint mais avec des
aberrations régionales teles que nombre
de régions se retrouvent avec des
assemblées tellement plétoriques
qu'elles seront à peu près
ingouvernables sans parler de la simple
difficulté de les abriter les métropoles
devaient être la grande institution
nouvelle capable de relancer le
dynamisme local elles sont vidées de
leur substance et ne sont plus des
collectivités de plein exercice comme
souhaité mais de simples EPCI à peine
plus puissants que les autres les
fusions de communes qui devaient ramener
leur nombre selon le comité baladure à
quelques milliers ne seront pratiquement
guerre possibles en tout cas massivement
l'unanimité des conseils et le recours
au référendum l'interdiront de fait bien
d'autres corrections ont été opérées qui
font dire à beaucoup qu'il s'agit
désormais d'une coquille vide dans cette
évolution le Sénat joue un grand rôle et
c'est pourquoi ne peut que regretter la
façon dont la majorité s'est rallé sans
brancher au textes de l'Assemblée
nationale lors de la CMP il y avait là
par la brutalité de la forme voulue par
le président de cette CMP quelque chose
d'humiliant pour le Sénat de toute façon
ni le Sénat ni l'Assemblée nationale
n'ont corrigé ce texte sur deux points
particulièrement néfastes la parité
amoindrie et la clause de compétence
remise en cause c'est-à-dire la remise
en cause de lois aussi fondatrices que
celle de 1871 et celle de 1884 sur les
municipalités tout cela est grave mais
au fond est-ce l'essentiel ou
l'accessoire le Parlement y a vu
l'essentiel ou en tout cas des éléments
majeurs mais je pense aussi que pour
l'exécutif c'était tout à fait
accessoire le président de la République
poursuivait deux objectifs un objectif
économico-financier et un objectif
politique et ces deux objectifs sont
atteints le premier objectif a été
atteint par une une voie parallèle celle
de la réforme fiscale faite sans réelle
concertation détour d'une simple loi de
finances au terme les collectivités ont
perdu leur autonomie financière elles
sont sous tutelle de l'État central cela
se fait sentir déjà pour les
départements et les régions dans leur
fonctionnement mais ce n'est rien par
rapport seront les choses lorsque ces
deux collectivités auront vraiment
taillé dans la dépense d'investissement
vu leur importance dans le financement
des équipements publics on risque de
bloquer gravement l'activité de notre
pays
les communes pour l'instant semblant
épargné mais chacun sait qu'il s'agit
d'une position tactique prise pour des
raisons conjoncturelles au Congrès des
mares de l'an dernier par le Premier
ministre et que l'objectif est bien de
faire rentrer tout le monde dans le rang
voulu par la Banque centrale européenne
et le Fond Monétaire International au
risque de casser encore plus ce qu'il
peut rester d'espoir de dynamisme de
l'économie française l'autre objectif
atteint est constitué par la création du
conseiller territorial je n'ai jamais
trouvé encore en privé en tout cas de
quelqu'un qui me vente les mérites de
cette invention baroque d'un
professionnel de la politique élu au
détriment d'un scrutin antérieur qui
assurait la parité hommees-femme siégant
dans deux assemblées aux objectifs
pourtant fort différents l'une de
proximité l'autre de programmation
chacun a bien compris que cet être
bizarre et ambivalent n'a pas pour
fonction première d'assurer une
administration plus rationnelle des
territoires de la République quoi qu'en
dise monsieur longuer son objectif est
purement politicien il s'agit derrière
les apparences et les fausses objectif
de corriger les effets dévastateurs pour
le pouvoir de sa propre politique il
faut regagner par la loi ce que les
scrutins successifs ont écrit les uns
après les autres regagner des régions et
des départements passés à gauche et pour
cela le président de la République
n'hésite pas à bouleverser
l'organisation des pouvoirs locaux à
casser ce qui marche et ce qui a fait
ses preuves j'entends bien de très hauts
responsables politiques de la
majorité dire plus ou moins ouvertement
que ça ne peut pas marcher mais si ça
marchera à une condition qui produira
elle-même de graves effet à la condition
de supprimer un échelon et celui qui est
visé et le département après monsieur
badur qui prenait l'évaporation du
département après monsieur Jupé c'est
Monsieur Copé qui qui court les
colloques et les débats pour dire
partout que cette loi n'est qu'une
première étape et qu'il faut fusionner
département et région pour en arriver là
il faudra une révision constitutionnelle
pas facile actuellement par la voie
parlementaire et elle risque d'être
encore plus difficile après les
prochaines échéances quant à la voie
référendaire on connait son incertitude
on en restera donc à cette construction
ou plutôt à cette destruction inachevée
vouis qui pour le coup j'ai presque fini
monsieur le Président qui pour le coup
ne marchera pas apparement apparemment
cela ne semble pas être le souci du du
président qui sera satisfait si sa
majorité reconquierre des positions
électorales décidément l'un d'entre vous
mes chers collègues de droite a raison
monsieur Sarkozi est bien un des
problèmes de la France Monsieur Sarkozi
mais la différence de Monsieur Villepin
nous ne disons pas il est grand temps
d'en finir avec la parenthèse c'est une
citation sarkoiste respectueux des
institutions et des échéances
programmées et quelle que soit notre
impatience nous la surmonterons cette
impatience pour respérer rétablir la
France institutionnel sur ses deux pieds
en 2012 en même temps que le droit à la
retraite à 60 ans merci mon cher
collègues la parole est maintenant au
président Philippe
an
pour cet
après-midi avez la parole mon cher
collègue bien messieurs les ministres
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure le président
Longuet dire que le moment était
historique je le
crois il est historique car il s'agit
pour nous pour nous tous de prendre nos
abilité devant l'histoire qui va
s'écrire on dit qu'il faut réformer je
suis tout à fait d'accord et j'ai
personnellement vter avec la majorité la
réforme des retraites mais c'est pas
parce qu'on appelle réforme un texte que
ce texte est bon or cette réforme voilà
toujours en direct la suite de cette
discussion sur les conclusions de la CMP
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
réforme des collectivités locales que
vous suivez depuis ce matin en direct
sur notre antenne et vous vous avez pu
constater les débats et bien restent
très passionnés et voir vif dans
l'hémicycle du C on a pu l'entendre il y
a quelques minutes à peine avec
l'intervention j'allais dire ardente
hein du président de la Commission de la
du groupe UMP au Sénat Gérard Longuet et
diverses autres également interventions
je pense en particulier à celle de
Jean-Pierre suur pour
l'opposition au nom du groupe socialiste
du Sénat c'est Hervé Moret qui nous a
rejoint et vous étiez il y a encore
quelques minutes àprè dans au pupitre
pour développer vos arguments je
rappelle que vous êtes membre de l'Union
centriste ici au Sénat et on a bien
mesuré tout l'embarras tout l'embarras
du groupe centriste et des centristes
sur ce texte par l'intermédiaire de de
de vos propos tout à l'heure
EMB Barras je ne sais pas mais je
constate plusieurs choses je constate
d'abord qu'au départ on devait avoir une
réforme ambitieuse une réforme qui
devait clarifier simplifier les
compétences qui devait générer des
économies qui devait réduire le
millefeuille territoor
tous ces points malheureusement ils ne
sont pas au rendez-vous et donc ça c'est
surtout un sentiment d'immense déception
entre ce que le président de la
République avait annoncé lors de de de
la présentation de la réforme il y a un
an et ce que l'on observe aujourd'hui et
puis lors de la deuxème lecture il y a
maintenant quelques mois on avait obtenu
quand même quelques avancées par rapport
à un texte vous l'avez compris qu'on
trouve finalement très médiocre on avait
obtenu quelques avancées et notamment le
fait que la loi la partie compétence
soit renvoyé un texte spécifique parce
que c'est suffisamment important pour
que ça ça fasse l'objet d'une loi
spécifique et tous les points qu'on a
obtenu toutes les avancées qu'on avait
obtenu ont disparu comme par magie au
cours de de de l'examen à l'Assemblée
puis de par la CMP donc aujourd'hui on
dit le compte n est pas et si le
gouvernement souhaite que nous votions
bien il faut qu'il fasse un effort pour
entendre davantage le Sénat alors c'est
très exactement ce que vous avez dit il
y a quelques minutes à la tribune de la
Haute Assemblée vous souhaiteriez quel
geste du gouvernement s'il peut encore
le faire dans les dans les 2 heures qui
restent de ce débat aujourd'hui le
gouvernement aujourd'hui est le seul à
pouvoir déposer des amendements puisque
quand on examine un texte de la CMP les
parlementaires ne peuvent pas déposer
d'amendements donc moi j'aimerais un
geste sur plusieurs sujet éventuellement
il y a la question des modes de scrutin
aujourd'hui on ne parle que du mode de
scrutin du Conseil Territorial mais il y
a un sujet pour moi très important qui
est celui du conseiller municipal le
gouvernement veut qu'à partir de 500
habitants il y ait dans les communes des
scrutins de listes bloqués sans
possibilité de panachage sans
possibilité de candidature individuelle
donc nous nous demandons que ce SOUIL
soit relevé
nous demandons également que la question
du cumulle des mandats qui avait été
introduite sur un amendement que j'avais
proposé en deème le qui disparu pas et
qui a disparu alors j'ai dit à la
tribune que c'était par enchantement je
crois que la réalité c'est que Monsieur
Copé ne veut pas en entendre parler
parce qu'il préside son intercommunalité
et bien je souhaite que cette question
soit aussi remise dans le texte parce
qu'on ne peut pas parler de
modernisation de la vie politique sans
sans revoir la question du cumul des
mandats voilà quelques gestes qui
pourrait aujourd'hui faire que
finalement ce texte que j'ai voté en
première et en deuxème lecture je
pourrais éventuellement le voter dans
conditions sans cela je ne le voterai
pas avec beaucoup de tristesse alors on
a entendu les uns et les autres
l'opposition comme la majorité euh la
majorité disant que le Sénat avait
finalement imposé quand même sa patte
sur ce texte et l'opposition évidemment
disant le contraire et parle
d'humiliation pour la Haute Assemblée
quel est votre sentiment sur la place
qui a eu finalement le Sénat dans cette
discussion complexe écoutez je trouve
que le Sénat a été très maltraité
puisque on a introduit à l'Assemblée
nationale en premier examen des
dispositions qui auraient dû venir ici
en première lecture sur des sujets
importants que sont le mode de scrutin
et les compétences il y a eu des
engagements qui ont été pris ici qui
n'ont pas été respectés il y a eu je
l'ai rappelé le fait qu'on a voté ce
texte avec certaines conditions et quand
je parle du renvoi des compétences à un
texte spécifique je rappelle que ça
avait été voté à l'unanimité moins 5
voix donc c'était pas un amendement de
circonstances un vote de circonstances
il y avait vraiment une grande unanimité
du Sénat on n'a pas respecté donc je
trouve que le Sénat n'a pas été bien
traité dans cette affaire quelques
heures du vote de ce texte quelle va
être votre position vous allez voter
cette loi vous allez vous abstenir ou
vous allez voter contre écoutez
j'attends de voir ce que le gouvernement
répond à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
une fois de plus j'ai tendu la main au
gouvernement et ça n'est pas la première
fois pour dire prenez en compte prenez
en compte les aspirations du Sénat et le
Sénat pourra voter la réforme on verra
ce que me répond le gouvernement tout à
l'heure et s'il ne vous répond rien vous
vous abstenez absolument au risque de
faire échec à ce texte oui mais je je ne
veux pas porter le poids d'une
éventuelle culpabilité même si les
centristes sont d'origine démocrate
chrétienne je veux dire si ce si ce
texte échoue le seul responsable ce sera
le gouvernement qui nous a apporté un
mauvais texte qui n'a pas pris en compte
nos demandes qui n'a pas écouté tout ce
qu'on a pu lui lui faire passer comme
message donc le seul et unique
responsable s'il y a échec mais nous
n'en sommes pas là ce sera le
gouvernement merci beaucoup Hervé Moray
de nous avoir rendu visite dans cette
salle des conférences et bien je vous
propose tout de suite de suivre la suite
de ces débats je vous rappelle euh sur
ses conclusions de la CMP sur la réforme
territoriale un orateur qu'on va écouter
avec beaucoup d'attention dans quelques
instants c'est Jean-Pierre chevedement
vous le savez à l'origine de cette
fameuse loi chevedement sur
l'intercommunalité dont il étéit
beaucoup question ce matin Jean-Pierre
chevedman à la tribune du Sénat vous
avez accepté le texte du Sénat à savoir
que la consultation serait appréciée non
pas dans le ressort du périmètre
concerné mais commune par commune c'est
une très modeste concession qui veut
dire qu'en fait on peut absorber une
commune contre l' vie du conseil
municipal mais pas je le reconnais
contre la majorité des
habitants le texte retenu même s'il met
un coup d'arrêt à la volonté
gouvernementale de fusionner les
communes traduit cependant une méfiance
certaine à l'égard des élus prenons un
exemple un EPCI de 15 deux communes
refusent la fusion que se passe-t-il on
peut être sûr que par une
interprétation abusive de la loi vous
allez pouvoir fusionner les 13 communes
volontaires et que resteront pendant un
temps deux villages gaulois qui finiront
par être absorbé voilà l'esprit demeure
c'est celui de la loi marcelain et vous
dévoyez l'esprit de l'intercommunalité
qui rendait inutile ce dispositif comme
une nouvelle en mettant au commun les
compétences stratégiques des communes et
qui permettaient de sauvegarder la
démocratie de proximité et le rôle
essentiel des maires et de leurs
adjoints à l'intérieur de chaque commune
cette méfiance se retrouve dans votre
texte sur l'intercommunalité je rappelle
que la loi de 1999 a été voté sous un
gouvernement de gauche à ma connaissance
il est vrai après une concertation
approfondi au sein de chaque assemblée
je rends hommage à un rapporteur de
l'époque Monsieur Mercier à côté de
Monsieur Effel au Sénat pour le travail
qu'ils ont fait mais ce sont des
différences de méthodes absolument
essentielles hein rien à voir avec ce
qui s'est fait avec ce projet de
loi pourquoi enfin je ne conteste pas la
nécessité d'achever la la carte de
l'intercommunalité mais pourquoi imposer
à la commission départementale de
coopération intercommunale une majorité
des 2 tiers pour pouvoir réformer la
carte au lieu d'inciter les préfets
messieurs les ministres à chercher le
consensus on leur donne quasiment les
pleins pouvoirs pour rattacher d'office
une commune ou même pour fusionner deux
EPCI il suffit d'une majorité simple des
communes rassemblant la moitié de la
population ne s'y oppose pas il suffit
que cette majorité simple ne s'y oppose
pas alors j'espère que la pratique de
l'intercommunalité ne sera pas faussé
par les nouvelles règles que vous avez
introduites j'ai l'impression que pour
aller au bout de cette réforme le
gouvernement utilise un marteau pilon
pour écraser une mouche dans une
démocratie apaisée les préfets devraient
inciter à rechercher par un dialogue
approfondi les solutions de bon sens que
les élus d'ailleurs sont capable de
trouver d'eux-mêmes mes collègues du
groupe rdseu et moi-même étions
tellement favorables à
l'intercommunalité que nous avons
proposer d'en faire la brique de base de
la constitution des territoires vous
avez rejeté cette possibilité en
refusant d'avancer au 1er mars 2013 la
date d'achèvement de la carte comme vous
le proposez le Sénat et en reportant
celle-ci au 30 juin 2013 là encore
l'Assemblée nationale a imposé son texte
en scrutant attentivement le texte issu
de la CMP j'aperçois non sans peine une
très modeste concession faite au Sénat
par le record de 2012 à 2015è j'ai fini
de l' de l'interdiction des financements
croisés mais le principe de
l'exclusivité des compétences entre
région et département demeure le texte
issu de la CMP ne fait aucune concession
au Sénat représent représentant légitime
des collectivités locales la Haute
Assemblée y compris monsieur Longuet
avait voté à 35 335 voix de majorité le
maintien de la clause de compétence
générale ce souhait a été piétiné hein
monsieur Longuet et vous-même vous avez
été piétiné même si vous manifestez une
certaine résilience si on entend par là
la capacité à reprendre forme après
avoir reçu un choc mais vous avez tous
été piétinés il n'y a pas de cadeau dans
le monde impitoyable de l'UMP hein au
centriste vous noferez même pas un PL
vous voulez conclure car le chacun
appréciera en son âme et conscience mais
il me semble que c'est la dignité du
Sénat qui est en jeu comme monsieur
mzard vous l'avez déjà indiqué la
majorité du groupe RDSE votera contre ce
texte merci
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Bernard verra groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateur du Parti de
Gauche vous avez la
parole monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministre mes
chers
collègues notre Haute Assemblée
peut-elle accepter que son rôle de
représentant des collectivités
territoriales que lui confère l'article
24 de la
Constitution soit remis en cause par un
acte
autoritaire ce nouveau passage en force
est inacceptable inacceptable parce
qu'il dénie aux élus locaux à leurs
associations opposé au contenu de la
réforme et plus encore après les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire le droit d'être
entendu in acceptable parce qu'il balait
l'acquis de la
décentralisation 30 années de
décentralisation ont conduit les
collectivités territoriales à investir
avec leurs moyens l'énergie et la
détermination de leurs élus à la
compétences de leurs cadres et souvent
l'appui des populations bien des champs
de la vie sociale et économique
développement d'infrastructure de
transport création et gestion
d'équipement public réalisation et
rénovation du parc de logement locatif
définition de politique d'urbanisme
émergence de pratiques culturelles
diversifiées action économique bien des
projets ont été portés par les
collectivités locales en leur nom propre
ou en association avec d'autres
partenair la décentralisation et
singulièrement l'application concrète de
la clause de compétence générale associé
à une plus grande maîtrise de l'outil
fiscal ont permis l'
des collectivités locales de la tutelle
de l'État elles ont appris à travailler
ensemble sur des projets rassembleur et
pertinent au regard des besoins de la
population et la décentralisation a été
un outil de développement
collectif au moment même où la crise
économique
s'approfondissait fonctionnant comme une
machine à exclure toujours plus de nos
compatriotes du paysage économique de la
vie sociale et ultime aboutissement de
la vie politique de la cité pourtant à
considérer les disposition relativ aux
finances locales dans cette loi à les
connecter avec la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle et l'ensemble des
mesures prises depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années pour contraindre les
ressources des collectivités ce sont
bien toutes ces avancées qui sont
brutalement mis en cause des entraves
sont posées à tout exercice de
l'initiative des élus locaux notamment
en interdisant les financements croisés
on veut dans de nombreux cas réduire les
communes au rôle de simple figurant
noyés dans un ensemble plus large
communauté urbaine métropole où le
pouvoir serait accaparé par les plus
importantes collectivités qui pourrai
imposer leurs vu et leurs priorités on
réduit la souplesse des ressources
financières des collectivités en
augmentant sans cesse la part des
dépenses obligatoires au point de
transformer certaines collectivités je
pense en particulier au département en
simple distributeur d'allocation dont la
quotité et les conditions d'attribution
sont fixées ailleurs on empiète sur le
pouvoir fiscal des élus locaux comme l'a
montré la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle qui va transformer sur
la durée en dotation à l'évolution
limitée ce qui était AAR avant une
ressource fiscale dynamique
représentative bien souvent des efforts
de développement économique accomplis
par les
collectivité de cette manière vous visez
à l'asphyie financière des collectivités
locales vous créez les conditions de la
disparition des communes et des
départements en réalité ce projet de loi
met en place une profonde
restructuration destruction de nos
institutions locales alors que le
gouvernement ne cesse de nous vanter
l'initiative privée la créativité
l'innovation faisant de l'audace
individuelle et du goût d'entreprendre
les fondements de son action voici qu'il
s'oppose avec force aux élus locaux
légitime représentant des populations en
les privant d'initiativ et de liberté de
gestion votre seul souci consiste à
faire participer les collectivités
territoriales à vos choix libéraux de
réduction à toute for
de la dépense publique alors que vous
savez pertinemment que que les
collectivités locales ne contribuent que
marginalement à l'accroissement des
déficits publics et la dette c'est
d'abord votre dette ce que porte ce
texte c'est un double mouvement de
concentration des pouvoirs et de
spécialisation la réforme territoriale
vous le savez les sénateurs toute cette
matinée et bien examine les conclusions
de cette commission mixte paritaire sur
ce texte de compromis entre l'Assemblée
nationale
et le texte de la Haute Assemblée les
débats se poursuivent ils vont en
principe se poursuivre jusqu'à jusqu'à
13h à mes côtés un président de région
et Dieu sait si les présidents de région
et bien sont concernés par cette réforme
territorial François patria bonjour vous
dirigez la région
Bourgogne qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui va
j'en doute pas je le sais qu'est-ce qui
va rester des régions une fois le vote
de ce texte si toutefois vote il y a
vote positif alors des fautes de
ferernble je vais essayer de faire c
même si je souhaite que ces propos soi
emprint d' un peu de de force je
considère
pour non pas caricaturer mais raccourcir
que ce texte de loi d'une part va
contonaliser les
régions ce qui est la pire des choses
puisqu'il va y avoir demain confusion de
gens et la région deviendra un syndicat
de conseillers généraux contonalisation
caporalisation puisque les présidents de
conseil régionaux vont être re au ordres
des présidents de conseil généraux
demain il n'y aura pas plus de proximité
mais il y aura moins de prise en compte
des grandes compétences que sont celles
de la région aujourd'hui quel sont
l'enseignement l'innovation la recherche
les transports la formation et enfin je
dirais carbonisation pour faire pour
faire un peu brutal mais c'est
l'affaissement des régions à terme qui
vont disparaître faute de moyens
financier faute de compéten bien définie
et puis surtout faute de entation
géographique intelligente c'est les
départements qui mine de rien et bien on
ont gagné dans la gestation de cette
réforme on voit bien que la loi de 2004
qui était entrée ici au Sénat
département régionaliste est sortie
départementaliste on voit bien le poids
des département ce qu'il a fait dans le
débat ici au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale mais je pense que c'est une
victoire en trompleœil ou à la pierus
parce que à terme ce sont à la fois les
régions et les départements qui vont
être affaiblis affaiblis dans leur dans
leurs moyens financiers affaiblis dans
leurs compétences affaiblis dans leurs
moyens d'action et que dans un premier
temps la région va s'affaer sous la
montée en puissance des représentants
départementaux mais qu'à terme les
départements eux-mêmes seront aussi mis
à mal alors on parle beaucoup de
décentralisation bien sûr cette réforme
elle s'inscrit dans ce dans dans ce
contexte décentralisé de la France cette
décentralisation elle va prendre un coup
avec cette réforme selon vous je pense
que nous vivons l'an 1 ou le jour 1 ici
de la recentralisation punitive moi j'ai
été conseiller territorial dans les
années 80 c'est une époque que je
n'aimerais pas revoir aujourd'hui que
nous allons revivre et je ne supporte
pas de voir des leçons de
décentralisation donné par des gens qui
ont combatttu toutes les grandes lois je
parle le loi de fer 82 que j'ai voté je
parle de la loi JX laat 92 sur
l'intercommunalité je parle ensuite des
lois et on vient d'entendre Jeanpierre à
l'instant tous ceux qui ont voté contre
ces lois voudrai devenir aujourd'hui des
chantres d'une décentralisation qu'ils
veulent affaiblir tout ça se résume à un
mauvais procès politique celui de la
mise à mal de ce que l'État considère
comme des contrepouvoirs aujourd'hui
alors on l'a c'est dit ici au Sénat
c'est les centristes c'est le groupe
centriste et la qualité de leur vote qui
va faire finalement la décision sur ce
texte ça sera ricraac on a vraiment
l'impression j'ai le sentiment que ce
sera le texte où le vote sera le plus
serré de de la mandature que je connais
que ce texte de loi va jouer à deux voix
que je ne suis pas
particulièrement optimiste pour ce qui
nous concerne mais mais qu'il reste que
dans cette affaire le Sénat ne sort pas
grandi parce qu'il s'agit d'une loi pour
les collectivités locales et que le
Sénat représente les collectivités
locales et que c'est l'Assemblée
nationale qui a imposé ses choix et ces
choix sont purement politiques
Jean-Pierre chavenement ind dit que le
Sénat était piétiné tout à l'heure oui
on peut dire un peu avec les les mots
fort ce qu'on ressent je crois que le
Sénat a été défait tout simplement Sénat
a été défait c'est un passage en force
qui naugure rien de l'avenir des
collectivités à la veille du congrès des
mères qui va commencer bientôt et à la
veille d'élections importantes qui vont
concerner les collectivités bientôt
alors rappelons simplement que sur ce
texte il y a des gens qui sont contents
ben c'est plutôt les maires et les
responsables d'intercommunalité de ce
côté-l il y a à peu près unanimité où ça
coince effectivement l'articulation des
compétences entre les départements et
les régions et vous êtes bien de placé
pour le savoir je crois que
l'intercommunalité s sort renforcer ce
texte et je ne suis pas maniquéen au
dire dire qu'il faille jeter tout le
texte sur l'intercommunalité il y a des
avancées sauf le fait qu'on crée
maintenant un étage dans le millefeuille
supplémentaire je ne vois pas bien
comment il pourra vivre demain là encore
comment les métropoles pourront-elles
vivre avec les départements et les
régions je ne le conçois pas bien ça
participera aussi de l'affaissement des
régions des départements de main donc
sur l'intercommunalité certes une
avancée que je ne conteste pas qui va
renforcer l'esprit intercommunal qui va
permettre aux communes de vivre mieux
d'assumer mieux leur souveraineté et
leur identité deain pour le reste ce
texte je le refuse totalement parce
qu'il va à l'encontre de ce que je pense
être une un pays moderne tous les grands
pays d'Europe aujourd'hui vivre avec
leur région la France seule voudrait
vous les voir disparaître aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup François patria d'avoir
été avec nous la suite de cette
discussion et bien elle se poursuit dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat juste un petite
précision dans quelques minutes et bien
nous ouvrirons une parenthèse dans cette
retransmission sénatoriale et nous nous
dirigerons vers Colomb les deux églises
où le le président de la République vous
voyez les premières images sur votre
écran est allé en compagnie du Premier
ministre François Fillon rendre hommage
au général de Gaulle vous le savez c'est
aujourd'hui 9 novembre que l'on célèbre
et bien le 40e
anniversaire de la mort de l'ancien
libérateur nous reviendrons donc à
Colombé dans quelques minutes mais sans
tarder c'est l'hémicycle du Sénat où se
poursuit euh cette discussion ce débat
sur la réforme éctoriale que nous allons
rejoindre merci encore François patria
de votre
visite eu des méthodes vous avez 5e
République je peux vous le dire par
ailleursag et ce moment j'étais en train
d'opérer un animal que la radio qui
marchait dans les tables annoncer la
mort du général de G merci de ce
témoignage à l'antenne Jacqueline gourau
on attend avec
impatience ses propos puisque vous le
savez elle est contre le texte de
réforme territoriale Jacqueline Gouro la
centriste représentant des conseils
municipaux pour siéger dans les
intercommunalités il y avait aussi cette
loi n'est-ce pas et on n'a jamais voulu
nous moi j'ai voté le conseiller
territorial je n'ai jamais voté
jusqu'ici contre cette loi j'ai toujours
attendu que le gouvernement fasse un
geste sur le mode de scrutin et quand on
dit la proportionnelle ça n'est pas vrai
nous sommes pour le scrutin majoritaire
à deux tours avec une dose de
proportionnelle je tiens à le Pr
préciser haut et fort ça existe déjà par
exemple aux élections municipales c'est
pas l'affaire d'en faire toute une
affaire enfin vraiment et donc
l'accumulation des motifs de refus que
je viens d'énumérer suffirait à
repousser ce texte mais ne serait-ce que
pour défendre monsieur le Président le
rôle et les missions de notre assemblée
je voterai contre ce texte avec
quelques-uns de mes euh collègues en
conscience et avec le sentiment d'une
occasion manquée
je voulais dire au secrétaire d'État aux
collectivités territoriales à qui on a
imposé dans cette loi enfin dans sa loi
qui était la loi interco tout ce
galimatia qui fait que aujourd'hui et
bien nous sommes obligés de considérer
que malgré le fait que nous aurions été
nombreux à vouloir voter la partie
intercommunalité de cette loi nous ne
pouvons pas le faire en conscience et je
vous remercie cependant de votre écoute
ainsi bien sûr que de l' écoute de mon
ami le ministre Michel Mercier en
agissant ainsi
disais-je en en agissant oui mais
l'amitié n'est pas contraire à la
liberté en agissant ainsi disais-je ce
sont les maires les conseillers généraux
et régionaux y compris ce que je connais
le mieux c'est-à-dire ceux de mon
département que je défends merci ma
cherre collègue la parole est maintenant
à Pier Colomba pour le groupe
socialiste avez la parole 6
minutes monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres et
chers collègues
transformer un projet de réforme qui
aurait pu être
consensuel en opération politicienne de
reconquête des collectivités
territoriales perdues ne pouvait
déboucher que sur un échec
collectif échec des initiateurs du
projet
eux-mêmes le nombre et l'enchevêtrement
des compétences des collectivités
locales est une source d'inefficacité et
de dépenses supplémentaires déclarait
Nicolas Sarkozi à Toulon le 26 septembre
2008 moins d'échelon c'est moins d'impôt
plus d'échelon c'est plus
d'impôt 2 ans après la clarification si
urgente brille encore par son obscurité
et l'on cherche en vain que l'échelon a
bien pu être supprimé étrange
clarification qui consiste à loger les
conseils généraux dans les conseils
régionaux à créer de nouveauvelles
catégories de PCI métropole et pôle
métropolitain de nouvelles catégories de
communes comme une nouvelle et et comm
unee déléguée quant aux économies avec
l'explosion des effectifs des
conseillers régionaux plus personne n'en
parle échec du Sénat qui n'a pas eu le
courage d'assumer fermement son rôle la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la République quel gâie
quand on pense au travail de la mission
bolo kratin g Gouro et au quasi
consensus où elle était parvenue sur des
questions essentielles et échec pour le
département toujours là mais pour
combien de temps l'assemblée régionale
nous dit l'un des théoriciens de la
réforme Hervé Fab brespi est formé
finalement de la réunion des conseils
généraux mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'on
préjuge de l'évolution ultérieure dans
notre système donc on va donner des
forces à chacune des collectivités et
l'évolution sera ce qu'en feront
finalement les acteurs on ne préjuge pas
de la disparition de la R rgion ou de
celle du département voilà qui garantira
une cohabitation sereine despédés du
pouvoir d'intervenir dans tout domaine
d'intérêt départemental vampirisé par
les métropoles là où elles existeront
tel est le nouveau département échec
pour les régions aussi c'est l'échelon
privilégié des réformateurs sauf que le
mode d'élection du conseiller
territorial rend illisible l'enjeu
régional et donne un poids politique
décisif au majorité départementale
coupler élection régional et
départementale c'est faire de cette
dernière l'élection essentielle pour
l'électeur et le système lui-même privé
de ressources et d'autonomie fiscale
affligé d'une assemblée plétorique sans
mode de scrutin lui garantissant une
majorité comme aujourd'hui que pourra
bien faire la région échec pour les
communes privé de la capacité de
maîtriser leur destin en s'associant
volontairement s'il en a aller autrement
l'élaboration du schéma départemental de
coopération intercommunale aurait été
confié à la CDCI qui en aurait décidé à
la majorité et non représentant du
gouvernement qui avec l'appui de 35 % de
la CDCI peut faire exactement ce qu'il
veut même ne pas appliquer le schéma
départemental une fois voté à ce jeu les
petites communes sont évidemment les
grandes perdantes en terme de
représentation au sein des conseils là
où les communes cent auront la CAP
d'imposer le tableau légal en terme de
représentation au sein des bureaux ce
n'est pas un hasard si la représentation
des commune au sein de la CDCI est passé
de 60 % à 40 % et celle des
intercommunalités de 20 % à 45 %. échec
aussi pour les territoires ruraux qui
verront le nombre de leurs élit diminuer
en même temps que la taille de leurs
canton
augmenteront plus d'élus de plus d'élus
de proximité là où ils sont le moins
util et moins là où ils le sont le plus
en zone rurale voilà la réforme le quin
le plus extravagant et celui des
conseillers territoriaux métropolitains
incompétent dans leur canton s'agissant
des compétences transférées au métropole
mais compétent pour l'ensemble des
autres cantons non métropolitains mais
échec aussi pour les territoires les
plus
urbanisés non seulement la région
parisienne est exclue du champ de la loi
mais celle-ci ne dit rien de l'ESS ci
comment assurer sur de vastes
territoires parfois discontinu la mise
en cohérence des intervention des
acteurs locaux dans les domaines
stratégiques que sont le transport le
développement économique et l'emploi
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
le logement les très grands événements
culturels et sportifs la discussion a
bien montré et le refus des amendements
qui ont été proposés encore plus que
loin de simplifier la situation la
nouvelle organisation urbe la complique
encore peut-être me répondra-ton
qu'insatisfaction générale est marque
d'équité tout le monde est en mécontent
ça veut dire que personne n avantagé
comme si la qualité d'une réforme se
mesurait au nombre de mécontents qu'elle
fait nos électeurs nous diront dans
quelques mois ce qu'ils en pensent le
gouvernement a fait son choix qu'il
l'assume l'Assemblée le suivra et aura
le dernier mot mais le Sénat
adoptera-t-il une réforme qu'il tient
majoritairement pour ni faitte ni
affaire s'il n'a pas le dernier mot il
peut au moins sauver
l'honneur merci mon cher collègue la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
Gérard